This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeart Radio
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。欢迎收听《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特博士，纽约市阿特里亚健康研究所女性健康与妇科系主任。我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，并直接为您带来关于中年女性健康的重要信息。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。即使这是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它呢？请在IHeart Radio上收听伊丽莎白·波因特博士的《解码女性健康》
app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal, Carl thought he was living a normal drama-free life until the messages started. Someone's not going to make it out of this alive. Every piece of evidence pointed to the wrong guy.
应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方。你毁了我。你不配拥有幸福。我是安德里亚·甘宁。在这一季的《背叛》中，卡尔以为自己过着正常、没有戏剧性的生活，直到那些信息开始出现。有人无法活着离开这里。每一条证据都指向了错误的人。
He was not going to stop unless we stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the I-Hawks. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If anyone wanted to commit a murder, up here would be the greatest place in the world to hide the body. But no one will find it. He acted friendly. He talked friendly. He sounded friendly. They all knew that I did the scary boogie stuff, and I said, maybe she'll find out where this girl is. I saw him violent. Backhanded her, pow! Listen to the devil's quarry.
除非我们阻止他，否则他不会停手。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《背叛》第六季。如果有人想谋杀，这里将是世界上隐藏尸体的最佳地点。但没人会找到它。他表现得很友好。他说话很友好。他听起来很友好。他们都知道我做了那些可怕的勾当，我说，也许她会找到这个女孩在哪里。我看到他很暴力。反手给了她一巴掌，砰！请收听《魔鬼的采石场》。
Season 2 in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Is there an epidemic against literature? More specifically, black literature. I'm Jack Quist-Peace Thomas, and on this season of the Black-Lit podcast, we're outside asking why. They don't want a whole bunch of little Ella bakers, Michael Waxes and Martin Luther King running around. And when you look at a lot of different cultures, they're like, we need to know where you came from. And considering this is Black-reading, month, the only real question is, what are you reading next? Listen to BlackLit from the Black Effect Podcast Network on our iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. The miles change how you move, but more importantly, they change how you show up for
第二季，在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《骨谷》频道。文学界是否存在流行病？更具体地说，是黑人文学。我是杰克·奎斯特-和平·托马斯，在这一季的《黑人文学》播客中，我们正在探讨原因。他们不希望到处都是像埃拉·贝克、迈克尔·韦克斯和马丁·路德·金那样的人。当你审视许多不同的文化时，他们会说，我们需要知道你来自哪里。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，唯一真正的问题是，你接下来要读什么？请在我们的iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《黑人文学》。里程改变了你的行动方式，但更重要的是，它们改变了你如何面对
your life. I'm Emily Abadi. On the hurdle with Emily Abadi podcast, I sit down with elite athletes, record holders, coaches, and everyday runners to unpack the mindset behind pushing through when things get tough. Because the discipline, grace, and grit you build out there on the That's what helps you show up as your best self everywhere else. I'd just love to say I never know who's watching. So you want to make sure you, you through and through, and you just stay true to who you are. Listen to Hurtle with Emily Abadi on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Jemis Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s.
你的生活。我是艾米丽·阿巴迪。在《与艾米丽·阿巴迪跨越障碍》播客中，我与精英运动员、纪录保持者、教练和日常跑步者坐下来，剖析在困难时期坚持下去背后的心态。因为你在那里建立的纪律、优雅和毅力，就是帮助你在其他任何地方展现出最好自己的东西。我只是想说，我永远不知道谁在看。所以你要确保你，从里到外，你只是忠于你自己。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《与艾米丽·阿巴迪跨越障碍》。大家好。我是杰米斯·斯派克，欢迎回到《你20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们20多岁意味着什么的播客。
our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast and welcome back to another episode where we break down the psychology behind everything from relationships to wellness trends to our 20s and today, cults. This is very unlike our usual episodes. If you're a long time listener, you know, but I couldn't help myself. I can't help myself. If there's one thing that fascinates me more than anything about human psychology. It is what drives people to leave the common ground of everyday society and join extremist alternative groups that often have very crazy ideas about the world that are highly irrational and mystical and a complete departure from reality, but people kind of believe it anyways. You know, groups like the one behind the
我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，欢迎回到另一集，我们在这里剖析从人际关系到健康趋势，再到我们20多岁的一切背后的心理学，今天的主题是邪教。这与我们平时的节目非常不同。如果你是长期听众，你就知道，但我忍不住。我无法控制自己。如果说有什么比人类心理学更让我着迷的东西，那就是是什么驱使人们离开日常社会的共同基础，加入极端主义的替代团体，这些团体通常对世界有非常疯狂的想法，高度非理性、神秘，完全脱离现实，但人们还是会相信。你知道，像那些在
Jones Town Massacre were like, how many was it? Nine hundred people. all committed suicide in the name of their cult or these groups that live entirely isolated from society believing that like some random guy from Idaho is like Jesus. Like what is the psychological appeal? And what gets someone often very normal people to a place of wanting to join and refusing to leave cults even when it harms them? This is what, well, exactly what we're exploring today, the deep and fascinating domain of cults. psychology. I also want to talk about modern cults or things that we label as cults. You know,
琼斯镇大屠杀背后的团体，有多少人？九百人。都以他们邪教的名义自杀了，或者这些完全与社会隔绝的团体，相信像爱达荷州的一个随便什么人就是耶稣。心理上的吸引力是什么？是什么让一个人，通常是非常正常的人，到了想要加入并拒绝离开邪教的地步，即使这伤害了他们？这就是，嗯，正是我们今天要探索的，邪教心理学这个深刻而迷人的领域。我还想谈谈现代邪教，或者我们称之为邪教的东西。你知道，
the cult of Taylor Swift, the cult of Donald Trump, the cult of Disney adults. What makes these things cult like? What gets people obsessed and devoted and fanatical over these people and over these experiences? We're also going to touch on a very huge ongoing debate. What is the difference between a cult and a religion? How do researchers separate the two? What are the criteria for labeling something a cults or labeling something a religion? And where does money come into that? Because, I don't know if you know, but a big part of whether something is a cult or not is not psychological, it is, and all does come down to taxes. It's a huge episode. I know there's so many little twists and turns. I don't want to waste any more time with this intro. But,
泰勒·斯威夫特的邪教，唐纳德·特朗普的邪教，迪士尼成人的邪教。是什么让这些东西像邪教？是什么让人们对这些人、对这些经历如此痴迷、虔诚和狂热？我们还将触及一个非常巨大的持续争论。邪教和宗教有什么区别？研究人员如何区分两者？给某物贴上邪教标签或给某物贴上宗教标签的标准是什么？金钱在其中扮演什么角色？因为，我不知道你是否知道，某物是否是邪教的一个重要部分不是心理上的，它是，而且确实归结为税收。这是一个巨大的节目。我知道有很多小转折。我不想在这个介绍上浪费更多时间。但是，
quick reminder if you're listening to this episode, I want to let you know you can now watch this episode, plus many more on Netflix. There will be a link in the description, so go and check it out. But without further ado, let's get into the complete psychology of cults. I think we all have an idea of what a cult is. You know what a cult is. You've seen it in movies, you've seen it on crime, podcast in the news. But if somebody asked for a definition, I think I'd be pretty stumped. I don't think I'd be able to give them an exact word-for-word idea. Like, you kind of know it when you see it. That's kind of, I think that's what I would go with, which is not a very good definition. Luckily, some very smart researchers have thought about
快速提醒，如果你正在听这一集，我想让你知道你现在可以在Netflix上观看这一集以及更多内容。描述中会有一个链接，所以去看看吧。但事不宜迟，让我们进入完整的邪教心理学。我想我们对什么是邪教都有一个概念。你知道什么是邪教。你在电影里见过，你在犯罪播客、新闻里见过。但如果有人要求给出一个定义，我想我会很困惑。我不认为我能给出一个逐字逐句的准确概念。就像，你看到它时就知道了。我想我会这么说，这不是一个很好的定义。幸运的是，一些非常聪明的研究人员已经思考了
this a lot deeper than me. And whilst it is actually a very debated topic, typically for something to be labeled a cults, it does have to meet a few criteria. So in short, cults are a social groups, So they have to be made up of more than a dozen or so people. B, they have to have unusual or some kind of extreme belief, whether it's religious, spiritual, or philosophical, and they have to have rituals that go along with that belief. C, they have to have extreme devotion to a particular person, object, or goal. D, it has to involve some kind of manipulation or control tactic
这个问题比我深刻得多。虽然这实际上是一个非常有争议的话题，但通常要将某物标记为邪教，它确实必须满足一些标准。简而言之，邪教是社会团体，所以它们必须由十几个人左右组成。B，它们必须有不寻常或某种极端的信仰，无论是宗教、精神还是哲学，并且它们必须有伴随这种信仰的仪式。C，它们必须对特定的人、物体或目标有极端的奉献。D，它必须涉及某种操纵或控制策略
that makes it hard to leave, means that people cannot willingly come and go. The most popular criteria for telling if something is a cult or not is called the Bight model of authoritarian control. This was developed by the researcher and the cult expert, Stephen Hassan, I think back in like the 90s. And Bight is obviously an acronym, which everyone loves an acronym. If you want to sell a theory, let me say, make it into another word.
这使得离开变得困难，意味着人们不能自愿来去。判断某物是否为邪教最流行的标准被称为威权控制的BITE模型。这是由研究人员和邪教专家斯蒂芬·哈桑在90年代开发的。BITE显然是一个首字母缩写词，每个人都喜欢首字母缩写词。如果你想推销一个理论，让我说，把它变成另一个词。
Like, that's my first bit of advice. People love acronyms, but bite, this acronym stands for B, behavior control. So a cult has to regulate the physical reality of somebody. So how they live, where they live, how they work, how they dress. It typically manages their money, their time. It requires a great deal of obedience physically and in terms of their lifestyle. I is information control. A cult will deliberately withhold or distort information.
就像，这是我的第一个建议。人们喜欢首字母缩写词，但BITE，这个首字母缩写词代表B，行为控制。所以邪教必须调节某人的物理现实。所以他们如何生活，住在哪里，如何工作，如何穿衣。它通常管理他们的金钱、时间。它在身体上和生活方式上要求极大的服从。I是信息控制。邪教会有意隐瞒或歪曲信息。
So this involves often minimizing, access to non-group thinking and really restricting communication with outsiders. T is thought control, so a cult wants members to believe in absolute truth. They often use thought-stopping techniques, yes, like separating people from their relatives, but also like chanting or meditation to block critical analysis and often requires members to reframe their memories to fit the group narrative. And E, it involves emotional control. A cult manipulates a person's feelings, primarily through fear and through the installation of irrational fears. So fears of the outside world, of others, of damnation, of punishment. But also, the cult leader
所以这通常涉及最小化对非团体思维的接触，并真正限制与外界的交流。T是思想控制，所以邪教希望成员相信绝对真理。他们经常使用思想停止技术，是的，比如将人们与亲属分开，但也像吟唱或冥想来阻止批判性分析，并且通常要求成员重构他们的记忆以适应团体叙事。E，它涉及情感控制。邪教通过恐惧和灌输非理性恐惧来操纵一个人的感受。所以对外部世界、他人、诅咒、惩罚的恐惧。但同时，邪教领袖
is presented as the one who will save them from this. And the cult leader cannot do any wrong. This bite model is really important because, as I mentioned in the intro, in popular culture, we've all heard people describe things as cults, which may or may not actually be cults, the cult of yoga, the cult of Disney adults, the cult of reality TV, the cult of Road Beauty, the cult of Lulu Lemon, whatever it is. But these things don't cause tremendous harm on a wide, like, member basis. They don't change someone's psychological reality. at least not most of the time. I'm sure you can really go in pretty deep and have that happen,
被呈现为将从这些中拯救他们的人。而且邪教领袖不会做错任何事。这个BITE模型非常重要，因为正如我在介绍中提到的，在流行文化中，我们都听过人们将事物描述为邪教，这些事物可能实际上是也可能不是邪教，瑜伽邪教、迪士尼成人邪教、真人秀邪教、罗德美容邪教、露露柠檬邪教，无论是什么。但这些东西不会在广泛的成员基础上造成巨大的伤害。它们不会改变一个人的心理现实。至少大多数时候不会。我相信你真的可以深入其中并让这种情况发生，
but there isn't some global leader trying to make that happen. What we're really trying to say when we describe these things as cult-like is that they inspire a kind of devotion. And it's not uncommon to see people highly dedicated to something and defend that very thing to an irrational end, but it's not a cult. I think especially with celebrity worship, though, and celebrity culture, maybe like the lines kind of blur, you know, and we do see very irrational behavior. When we form a parasycial bond with somebody, we defend them like a friend, but also like a god. And it's intense, but is it a cult? So let's take the example of Taylor Swift, who I think is the center of like more than anything else cultish accusations.
但并没有一个全球性的领导者试图让这种情况发生。当我们把这些东西描述为像邪教时，我们真正想说的是，它们激发了一种奉献精神。看到人们对某事高度投入并为那件事辩护到非理性的地步并不罕见，但这并不是邪教。不过，我认为特别是在名人崇拜和名人文化中，界限可能有点模糊，你知道，我们确实看到了非常非理性的行为。当我们与某人形成准社会纽带时，我们像朋友一样捍卫他们，但也像神一样。这很强烈，但这是邪教吗？让我们以泰勒·斯威夫特为例，我认为她是比其他任何东西都更像邪教指控的中心。
In researching this episode, I cannot tell you how many PhD dissertations, articles, podcasts, the like, are written on the cultish. of Taylor Swift. Let's look at the evidence that, you know, she's this big mastermind running this like huge domain of followers. And then we'll look at the evidence against. So firstly, she does have a dedicated social group, the Swifties. That name alone separates you from being in or out of the group, which is fundamental to group think identity, a huge component of culture-thinking. Within the group, there can be extreme defensiveness and the policing of narratives. Like, so when any criticism of Swift comes in, it's met with very fierce backlash, she can do no wrong. The way that her swifties, like, defend her at every turn no matter what, that does indicate an irrational loyalty
在研究这一集时，我无法告诉你写了多少关于泰勒·斯威夫特邪教倾向的博士论文、文章、播客等。让我们看看证据，你知道，她是这个巨大的主谋，经营着这个巨大的追随者领域。然后我们将看看反对的证据。首先，她确实有一个专注的社会群体，Swifties。仅那个名字就将你与群体内或群体外区分开来，这是群体思维认同的基础，是邪教思维的一个巨大组成部分。在群体内部，可能会有极端的防御性和对叙事的监管。比如，当任何对斯威夫特的批评出现时，都会遭到非常激烈的反击，她不会做错任何事。她的Swifties无论如何都在每一回合捍卫她的方式，这确实表明了一种非理性的忠诚
that makes her almost inhuman. So incapable of doing wrong, forgivable at every turn, which mimics the idea of somebody who is godlike or a godlike figure. What's more, I would say many fans experience a very deep parasocial relationship to her that feels two-sided, even if it's one-sided. And this includes a strong sense of personal intimacy and like a spiritual connection to her lyrics. Swifties pour over every word that she writes, almost like scripture, right? The same way people pour over their Bibles. They feel that like what she's writing, her music is for them and them alone.
这使她几乎非人。所以无法做错事，在每一回合都可以被原谅，这模仿了某人是神一样或神一样人物的想法。更重要的是，我会说许多粉丝对她有一种非常深刻的准社会关系，感觉是双向的，即使它是单向的。这包括一种强烈的个人亲密感，就像与她的歌词有精神联系一样。Swifties仔细研读她写的每一个字，几乎就像经文一样，对吧？就像人们仔细研读他们的圣经一样。他们觉得她写的，她的音乐是为他们和他们自己准备的。
There is an emotional attachment to these words. there is a sense that her lyrics don't just give life like meaning or advice or solace, but they kind of ride out the truth or a correct way to live life or to think about life. Other examples of cult-like behavior include dedicated rituals. Yeah, this is kind of a fun exercise, but it's true, like making friendship bracelets, decoding cryptic Easter eggs in her music. Those are rituals. Treating concerts like communal events, kind of cult-like.
对这些词有一种情感依恋。有一种感觉，她的歌词不仅赋予生活意义或建议或慰藉，而且它们以某种方式写出了真相或生活或思考生活的正确方式。像邪教行为的其他例子包括专门的仪式。是的，这是一种有趣的练习，但这是真的，比如制作友谊手链，解码她音乐中神秘的复活节彩蛋。那些是仪式。把演唱会当作公共活动，有点像邪教。
During her last tour, there were reports that fans experienced memory loss, confusion, hysteria. That's similar to reports of religious mass hysteria we see in cults like the people's temple and more. But there is a big difference. And there's a reason I wanted to go into this. There is a big difference between being a diehard Swifty and being part of a cult. Firstly, to be a Swifty doesn't involve coercion or isolation. Fans are free to leave, they're free to lose interest, they are free to listen to other music at any time without facing threats or isolation from their real world live. Somebody isn't going to come and hurt them.
在她上次巡演期间，有报道称粉丝经历了记忆丧失、困惑、歇斯底里。这类似于我们在人民圣殿教等邪教中看到的宗教大规模歇斯底里的报道。但有一个很大的区别。我想要深入研究这一点是有原因的。成为一个铁杆Swifty和成为邪教的一部分之间有很大的区别。首先，成为一个Swifty不涉及胁迫或孤立。粉丝可以自由离开，他们可以自由失去兴趣，他们可以随时自由听其他音乐，而不会面临来自他们现实世界生活的威胁或孤立。没有人会来伤害他们。
Additionally, the Swifties are just another iteration of a type of fan behavior that we've seen time and time again. We saw it with the Beatles. We saw it with Elvis, Michael Jackson, with BTS. for the majority of people, they may adore her, but she is not the complete and utter centre of their lives in a way that they are so scared of her and the ideology that they will not leave. You know, most people will likely have friends or family members that are not Swifties that are out of these so-called cults. And most people will say, like, I don't live and die according to Taylor Swift's lyrics. It's interesting, though, there's a
此外，Swifties只是我们一次又一次看到的粉丝行为类型的另一种迭代。我们在披头士乐队身上看到了它。我们在猫王、迈克尔·杰克逊、BTS身上看到了它。对于大多数人来说，他们可能崇拜她，但她并不是他们生活的完全和绝对中心，以至于他们如此害怕她和意识形态，以至于他们不会离开。你知道，大多数人可能会有不是Swifties的朋友或家人，他们不在这些所谓的邪教中。大多数人会说，我不根据泰勒·斯威夫特的歌词生活和死亡。不过，这很有趣，有一个
it's an important exercise of like how things do overlap. And it raises that second important point that we made in the beginning, which is what distinguishes not just a person or a pop star from being a cult, but a religion, a real true religion from being a cult. Some people might say there's no difference. Some people. Let's talk about it though. Our religion, like a cult, is an organized social group. Like a cult, there is often a uniform way of thinking. There is often an absolute truth centered around God. There are traditions and sacred rituals. There may even be fear, often of hell or some kind of damnation.
这是一个重要的练习，关于事物是如何重叠的。它提出了我们在开始时提出的第二个重要点，即不仅是将一个人或流行歌星与邪教区分开来，而且是将宗教，一个真正的宗教与邪教区分开来。有些人可能会说没有区别。有些人。不过让我们谈谈它。一个宗教，像一个邪教，是一个有组织的社会团体。像一个邪教，通常有一种统一的思维方式。通常有一个以神为中心的绝对真理。有传统和神圣的仪式。甚至可能存在恐惧，通常是对地狱或某种诅咒的恐惧。
And there may be some kind of coercive control in some situations. But in general, there is an important distinction, the same way there is an important distinction between Taylor Swift and cults. Most healthy religions offer kind of an open-door policy. They basically say, hello, please come in. If you want to join us, we'd love to have you. For as long as you like, you can come and go. There's no sign up for your commitment required unless you'd like to, of course.
在某些情况下可能存在某种强制控制。但总的来说，有一个重要的区别，就像泰勒·斯威夫特和邪教之间有一个重要的区别一样。大多数健康的宗教提供一种开放政策。他们基本上说，你好，请进来。如果你想加入我们，我们很乐意有你。只要你喜欢，你可以来去自如。除非你愿意，否则不需要注册你的承诺。
Come if you'd like, stay if you wish, leave if you wish as well. That is a healthy religion. And healthy religions also encourage people to engage with broader society. They allow you to maintain relationships with family and friends outside of the faith. they allow you to participate in normal civic life. If they don't, that's when they become a cult. There's also often not totalitarian control other than from like God or Jesus or other or higher power. I will say we've seen a lot of instances of religious leaders misusing their power in a way that would be seen as a form of totalitarian, cruel, harmful control. You know, the Catholic Church
如果你愿意就来，如果你希望就留下，如果你希望也可以离开。那是一个健康的宗教。健康的宗教也鼓励人们参与更广泛的社会。他们允许你与信仰之外的家人和朋友保持关系。他们允许你参与正常的公民生活。如果他们不这样做，那就是他们变成邪教的时候。除了来自上帝或耶稣或其他更高力量之外，通常也没有极权控制。我会说我们已经看到了很多宗教领袖滥用权力的例子，这会被视为一种极权、残酷、有害的控制形式。你知道，天主教会
just got to single them out. That's probably the best example in recent memory. But still, that's one segment of the religion. That is not the entire thing. A cult, almost all aspects of it, will be highly authoritarian. And it's almost always centered around a single living leader. They actively isolate members from family. They encourage them to cut them out. And I feel like I'm really laboring over this point. It's just intensely psychological. It's everything. it dictates everything in their lives. Another critical element which distinguishes a cult from a religion, which I read about in a paper from the University of California, Berkeley.
只是不得不把他们挑出来。这可能是最近记忆中最好的例子。但即便如此，那只是宗教的一部分。那不是整个事情。邪教，几乎它的所有方面，都将是高度威权的。而且它几乎总是以一个单一的在世领袖为中心。他们积极地将成员与家人隔绝。他们鼓励他们切断联系。我觉得我真的在这一点上费尽心思。这只是强烈的心理学。这就是一切。它决定了他们生活中的一切。另一个区分邪教和宗教的关键要素，我在加州大学伯克利分校的一篇论文中读到过。
This paper is titled, Who Decides the Difference Between a Cult and a Religion? I was so surprised by this. It comes down to something very arbitrary, which is taxes. Religions are tax exempt, cults are not. And who decides whether religion is a religion? The government. And sometimes they get it wrong. It all comes back to money, to be honest.
这篇论文的标题是《谁决定了邪教和宗教之间的区别？》。我对此感到非常惊讶。它归结为一些非常武断的东西，即税收。宗教是免税的，邪教不是。谁决定宗教是否是宗教？政府。有时他们弄错了。老实说，这一切都归结为金钱。
For example, the Church of Scientology. Most of us would say cult, right? It's actually a religion. They don't pay taxes. They are deemed by the IRS to be a legitimate religion, despite all we know, despite the disappearances of members, despite isolationism, despite fearmongering. It is not just harm that determines if something's going to be a cult. many layers of things and eventually, as I said, it comes back to money. How much money,
例如，科学教派。我们大多数人会说是邪教，对吧？它实际上是一个宗教。他们不纳税。尽管我们所知的一切，尽管成员失踪，尽管孤立主义，尽管散布恐惧，他们被国税局视为一个合法的宗教。不仅仅是伤害决定了某物是否会成为邪教。许多层面的东西，最终，正如我所说，它归结为金钱。多少钱，
how many lawsuits basically does it take to buy your way out of cult status and into the status of a legitimate religion? So to get more into the emotional human side of things, how do cults even form in the first place? I think we need to take a short break here before we get into this research because it is truly fascinating and the personality of cult leaders is an episode of its own. We're going to try and cover it all after this short break. If anyone wanted to commit a murder, up here would be the greatest place in the world to hide the body. But no one will find it. He acted friendly. He talked friendly. He sounded friendly. They all knew that I did the scary boogie stuff and they said maybe she'll find out where
基本上需要多少诉讼才能买通你的邪教地位并进入合法宗教的地位？所以为了更多地进入情感的人性方面，邪教是如何形成的？我想我们需要在这里休息一下，然后再进入这项研究，因为它确实非常迷人，邪教领袖的个性本身就是一集。我们将在这次短暂休息后尝试涵盖所有内容。如果有人想谋杀，这里将是世界上隐藏尸体的最佳地点。但没人会找到它。他表现得很友好。他说话很友好。他听起来很友好。他们都知道我做了那些可怕的勾当，他们说也许她会找到
this girl is. I saw him violent. Backhanded a bow! And that's exactly what made us all think he had something to do with it. The clock is ticking down and the woods are calling. There are a lot of demons in Putnam County. But I've met the devil and he's real. I'm Paul Solitarev, and this is season two of the devil's quarry. Listen to the devil's quarry season two on the IHeart radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
这个女孩在哪里。我看到他很暴力。反手给了她一巴掌！而这正是让我们所有人都认为他与此有关的原因。时钟在倒计时，树林在呼唤。普特南县有很多恶魔。但我见过魔鬼，他是真实的。我是保罗·索利塔列夫，这是《魔鬼的采石场》第二季。请在IHeart Radio应用程序上收听《魔鬼的采石场》第二季。Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方。
And to hear The Devil's Quarry Season 2 Add free with exclusive content, subscribe to Lava for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal, we meet Carl Bryant. Carl thought he was living a normal, drama-free life
要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《魔鬼的采石场》第二季，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Lava for Good Plus。你毁了我。你不配拥有幸福。我是安德里亚·甘宁。在这一季的《背叛》中，我们遇到了卡尔·布莱恩特。卡尔以为自己过着正常、没有戏剧性的生活
until the messages started. You will have hell to pay. For nine months, someone infiltrated every aspect of Carl's life threatening to ruin him. Cyberstalking, swatting, extortion, impersonation. And then the text threats escalated. Someone's not going to make it out of this alive. It's playing out in real life, not just on the phone. Every piece of evidence pointed to one man.
直到那些信息开始出现。你会付出代价的。九个月来，有人渗透到卡尔生活的方方面面，威胁要毁掉他。网络跟踪、SWATing（虚假报警）、勒索、冒充。然后短信威胁升级了。有人无法活着离开这里。它在现实生活中上演，不仅仅是在手机上。每一条证据都指向了一个人。
But every piece of evidence. was a lie. He was not going to stop unless we stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, everybody, it's me, W. Compte Bell. This season of my podcast who's with me, I speak with two-time Emmy winner and weirdly one of my best friends, Kevin Avery. Everything up to that point, build you as a comic, us going on the road, doing Battle Mountain and Ely. You took me, you were one of the first people took me on the road, which is funny because at the time I was like, I don't know if I like this guy.
但每一条证据。都是谎言。除非我们阻止他，否则他不会停手。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听《背叛》第六季。大家好，是我，W.康普特·贝尔。这一季我的播客《谁和我在一起》，我与两届艾美奖得主、奇怪的是我最好的朋友之一，凯文·艾弗里交谈。在那之前的一切，把你塑造成一个喜剧演员，我们去路上，做Battle Mountain和Ely。你带了我，你是第一批带我上路的人之一，这很有趣，因为当时我想，我不知道我是否喜欢这家伙。
With rapper, actor, David Diggs. The jump off for me was Hamilton and it was the most popular thing in a very long time. But it was still, for me, it was me and my friends making something dumb. Bruce Lee's daughter and Brandon Lee's sister, Shannon Lee. Back to your initial point of stewarding my father's legacy and giving my energy to that. you're lending your life to stewarding somebody else's life. Listen to Who's With Me with Debbie Kumabelle on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health.
与说唱歌手、演员大卫·迪格斯。对我来说，跳板是《汉密尔顿》，它是很长一段时间以来最受欢迎的东西。但对我来说，它仍然是我和我的朋友们在做一些愚蠢的事情。李小龙的女儿和李国豪的妹妹，香农·李。回到你最初关于管理我父亲遗产并为此贡献我的精力的观点。你把你的生命借给管理别人的生命。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听黛比·库马贝尔的《谁和我在一起》。欢迎收听《解码女性健康》。
I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecology at the Adria Health Institute in New York City. On this show, I'll be talking to top researchers and top clinicians, asking them your burning questions and bringing that information about women's health and mid-life. directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. It can be such a struggle for our quality of life, but even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? The types of symptoms that people talk about is forgetting everything. I never used to forget things. They're concerned that, one, they have dementia, and the other one is, do I have ADHD? There is unprecedented promise with regard to cannabis and cannabinoids, to sleep better, to have less pain, to have better mood and also to have better day-to-day life.
我是伊丽莎白·波因特博士，纽约市阿特里亚健康研究所女性健康与妇科系主任。在这个节目中，我将与顶尖的研究人员和顶尖的临床医生交谈，询问他们你最关心的问题，并将关于女性健康和中年健康的信息直接带给你。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。这对我们的生活质量来说可能是一种挣扎，但即使它是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它呢？人们谈论的症状类型是忘记一切。我以前从不忘记事情。他们担心，第一，他们患有痴呆症，另一个是，我患有ADHD吗？在大麻和类大麻素方面有前所未有的希望，可以睡得更好，减少疼痛，有更好的情绪，也有更好的日常生活。
Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you're listening now. I'm former U.S. Women's National Soccer team player Carly Lloyd. I'm Fox Sports Reporter Jenny Taft. And on our new podcast, whatever it takes, we're talking motherhood, marriages, careers, and figuring out how to balance it all. And we'll discuss the game that brought us together because nothing is off limits. Do you remember your initial reaction when,
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您现在收听的地方收听伊丽莎白·波因特博士的《解码女性健康》。我是前美国国家女子足球队队员卡莉·劳埃德。我是福克斯体育记者珍妮·塔夫脱。在我们的新播客《不惜一切代价》中，我们谈论母亲、婚姻、职业，并弄清楚如何平衡这一切。我们将讨论让我们走到一起的比赛，因为没有什么是不允许的。你还记得你最初的反应吗，当
Fox called you to be a part of the World Cup? I was like, no, I don't want to do it. You said no? I played with players that didn't, I don't think that they really, truly love the game. I found the love with the ball at my foot. But in my head, it was the long game. It was like, I don't care what I'm being asked to do at Fox. I'm going to go get some reps, and I'm going to learn it and love it and embrace it.
福克斯打电话让你参加世界杯？我说，不，我不想做。你说不？我和那些我不认为他们真正热爱比赛的球员一起踢球。我在脚下有球时找到了爱。但在我的脑海里，这是一场长期的比赛。就像，我不在乎福克斯要求我做什么。我要去练习，我要学习它，爱它并拥抱它。
He said, this group of people will never be in the same room as part of the same team ever again. in your life. And it is your job to make sure that you enjoy the moment. You're proud of what you accomplish together. Listen to whatever it takes with Carly Lloyd and Jenny Taft on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I feel like these days, you and I have seen enough cult documentaries to know the warning signs. We kind of get it. That doesn't look good. We don't want to join that kind of organization. However, there are an estimated 10,000 active cults in the United States alone. How do, like, knowing what we know, how do people continue to join these things? How do they even start? So cults often start with one person. This is what
他说，这群人再也不会作为同一个团队的一部分出现在同一个房间里了。在你的生命中。你的工作是确保你享受这一刻。你为你一起取得的成就感到自豪。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何您获取播客的地方收听卡莉·劳埃德和珍妮·塔夫脱的《不惜一切代价》。我觉得这些天，你和我已经看了足够的邪教纪录片来知道警告信号。我们有点明白了。那看起来不太好。我们不想加入那种组织。然而，仅在美国就有估计10,000个活跃的邪教。人们怎么，就像，知道我们所知道的，人们怎么继续加入这些东西？它们甚至是怎么开始的？所以邪教通常从一个人开始。这就是
we call the charismatic leader or the visionary. This person has an idea of the world that they want to impress on others. Now, sometimes this is, and it begins as a legitimate and sincere view that they think would genuinely guide or help other people. Often though, this person does normally have an underlying desire for something more. They want control, they want power, they want financial gain, they want adoration. And I was reading this paper that said, a big warning sign is that this person has often tried to get that thing they want through other means unsuccessfully first. So they have tried to gain power through maybe a formal religion before getting kicked out, through business and money or fame before they've tried
我们称之为魅力型领袖或远见者。这个人对世界有一个想法，他们想给别人留下深刻印象。现在，有时这是，它始于一个合法和真诚的观点，他们认为这会真正指导或帮助其他人。然而，通常这个人确实有对更多东西的潜在渴望。他们想要控制，他们想要权力，他们想要经济收益，他们想要崇拜。我正在读这篇论文，上面说，一个大的警告信号是，这个人通常首先尝试通过其他方式不成功地获得他们想要的东西。所以他们试图通过也许一个正式的宗教获得权力，然后被踢出，通过商业和金钱或名声，在他们尝试之前
this cult thing through control of their family. This is a very critical thing. A lot of cults start not just with an individual, but with an individual and their family. The family is often the first victim, the first people to be brought in. There was research published in 2004 in the Encyclopedia of Religious Psychology and Behavior that also identified how most, not all, but most cult leaders share a specific personality type. If you have done any kind of psychology course, you might guess what this is. It's called the Dark Triad, which combines narcissism, Machiavellianism, and psychopathy, otherwise known as a cluster B personality type. They are seductive, they are impulsive, they are emotionally intense, they have a flair for
这个邪教的东西通过控制他们的家庭。这是一件非常关键的事情。许多邪教不仅始于个人，而且始于个人及其家庭。家庭通常是第一个受害者，第一批被带进来的人。2004年在《宗教心理学与行为百科全书》上发表的研究也确定了大多数，不是全部，但大多数邪教领袖共享一种特定的个性类型。如果你做过任何心理学课程，你可能会猜到这是什么。它被称为黑暗三角，结合了自恋、马基雅维利主义和精神病态，也称为B类人格类型。他们是诱人的，他们是冲动的，他们是情感强烈的，他们有天赋
grandiosity, a chronic fear of abandonment. All of this makes them basically like a social weapon because they have such a low self-esteem and they have all the tools to execute their desire to gain other people's approval. This is an important point to emphasize. These people are brilliant, to be honest, and nobody really willingly joins a cult. They join this person because they think they're amazing. They join a movement that looks good and helpful and at first seems really incredible. They, you know, they've probably encountered something that they really think is going to change their life. Any good cult, good, in quotation marks, knows that the best kind of indoctrination takes time and they will go about it slowly. They really, it's like putting
宏大，对被遗弃的慢性恐惧。所有这些使他们基本上像一种社会武器，因为他们有如此低的自尊，并且他们拥有执行他们获得他人认可的愿望的所有工具。这是一个需要强调的重要点。老实说，这些人很聪明，没有人真正自愿加入邪教。他们加入这个人是因为他们认为他们很棒。他们加入了一个看起来不错且有帮助的运动，起初看起来真的很不可思议。他们，你知道，他们可能遇到了他们真正认为会改变他们生活的东西。任何好的邪教，好的，在引号中，都知道最好的灌输需要时间，他们会慢慢地进行。他们真的，这就像把
a frog in boiling water. When a potential recruit meets, let's say a cult member, they are normally showered with love, they are showered with validation, that feels amazing. Love bombing is the term that we would give that in a relationship. And in fact, the term love bombing was actually first coined by a cult, a cult known as the Unification Church. And members of this cult were basically formally instructed to flood new recruits with gifts and flattery and warmth, and they wanted them to feel really valued and safe. They called that the hook. And then once someone, somebody was addicted to this feeling, the affection would end and it would be replaced by very strict rules and by emotional manipulation. And by then it's too late. It's like a relationship. By then,
一只青蛙放在沸水中。当一个潜在的新兵遇到，比如说一个邪教成员，他们通常会被爱淹没，他们会被验证淹没，这感觉很棒。爱轰炸是我们会在一段关系中给出的术语。事实上，爱轰炸这个词实际上是由一个邪教，一个被称为统一教会的邪教首次创造的。这个邪教的成员基本上被正式指示用礼物、奉承和温暖淹没新兵，他们希望他们感到真正被重视和安全。他们称之为钩子。然后一旦有人，某人对这种感觉上瘾了，这种感情就会结束，它会被非常严格的规则和情感操纵所取代。到那时已经太晚了。这就像一段关系。到那时，
they feel so indebted and bonded to this person or this group. They deeply believe that the good feelings are going to come back and they can't leave. That is the origin of the term love bombing. It's cult recruitment. Something else happens at the stage as well. Even if the person doesn't want to leave, so they're having a lot of fun with their new friends and with their fun cult leader, cults know that their family and friends will definitely want them to leave and that they can be very, very persuasive. So they're going to do everything in their power to either cut them out or bring them in. They will convince them that they're evil if they don't want to join the cult. They don't love them like the cult does. They may force them to surrender
他们感到如此亏欠并与这个人或这个团体结合在一起。他们深信好的感觉会回来，他们无法离开。这就是爱轰炸这个词的起源。这是邪教招募。在这个阶段也会发生其他事情。即使那个人不想离开，所以他们和他们的新朋友以及他们有趣的邪教领袖玩得很开心，邪教知道他们的家人和朋友肯定会希望他们离开，而且他们可能非常有说服力。所以他们会尽其所能要么切断他们，要么把他们带进来。如果他们不想加入邪教，他们会说服他们是邪恶的。他们不像邪教那样爱他们。他们可能会强迫他们投降
their money and their belongings and their identity and their bodies to the cult leader. Sometimes, you know, new members are compelled to marry people. They've just met really, really quickly. They may use deprivation, punishment, other tactics to wear this person down after they've encountered the most amazing feeling of love they ever have. They make them swear oaths, anything that's going to psychologically hook them in. This is when the love is replaced by fear, two of the most powerful and convincing human emotions mixing together in this extreme circumstances. And two emotions that are often
他们的金钱、他们的财物、他们的身份和他们的身体给邪教领袖。有时，你知道，新成员被迫与他们刚刚遇到的人结婚，真的，真的很快。他们可能会使用剥夺、惩罚、其他策略来磨损这个人，在他们遇到了他们有过的最美妙的爱之后。他们让他们发誓，任何会从心理上钩住他们的东西。这就是爱被恐惧取代的时候，两种最强大和令人信服的人类情感在这种极端情况下混合在一起。以及两种经常
biologically and psychologically impossible to ignore. Our brain is hardwired to pay attention to love and fear. The cult goes, you know, we love you. No one else does. If you leave, like, you're going to give up this love, but you're also going to give up so much more. You're going to be punished. Your way of life is going to be destroyed. We're going to hurt you. It's like a scaled up version of a toxic relationship with a manipulative controlling partner, but it's happening with this whole group of other people. I should say, I've emphasized cults which operate around like a centralized person. Important time to say not all cults have this. And this can lead people to believe that what they're experiencing isn't a cult if there isn't a leader. They think it's a community.
在生物学和心理学上无法忽视的情感。我们的大脑天生就会关注爱和恐惧。邪教说，你知道，我们爱你。没有其他人这样做。如果你离开，就像，你将放弃这种爱，但你也将放弃更多。你将受到惩罚。你的生活方式将被摧毁。我们会伤害你。这就像一个与操纵性、控制性伴侣的有毒关系的放大版本，但它正在与这群其他人一起发生。我应该说，我强调了围绕像一个中心化的人运作的邪教。重要的时间说并非所有邪教都有这个。这可能导致人们相信，如果没有领袖，他们所经历的不是邪教。他们认为这是一个社区。
They think it's a friendship. In this situation where there isn't a charismatic leader, followers of said cult brainwash each other instead. In the absence of this one person in a decentralized cult, it's called, the ideology replaces the leader or a specific text or an overarching conspiracy theory, a shared lifestyle. That becomes the ultimate authority and the ultimate truth. Any deviation or questioning of this doctrine is quickly punished not by the leader, but by the community itself. In this situation, extreme peer pressure kind of replaces top-down commands. Members constantly police one another.
他们认为这是一种友谊。在这种没有魅力型领袖的情况下，所述邪教的追随者反而互相洗脑。在去中心化邪教中缺少这个人的情况下，它被称为，意识形态取代了领袖或特定的文本或一个总体的阴谋论，一种共同的生活方式。那成为最终的权威和最终的真理。对这种教义的任何偏离或质疑都会很快受到惩罚，不是由领袖，而是由社区本身。在这种情况下，极端的同伴压力取代了自上而下的命令。成员们不断地监管彼此。
They expel or shun people as well. And in the digital age, online communities and online cults do this more than anybody else. You know, the mob mentality quickly kind of pushes and punishes dissenters. To be part of the group, you have to believe exactly what they believe. they want radical conformity. And there are countless examples of this on the internet. QAnon is a massive one. There is no central charismatic leader who is holding political, physical rallies
他们也驱逐或回避人们。在数字时代，在线社区和在线邪教比任何人都更这样做。你知道，暴民心态很快地推动和惩罚异议者。要成为团体的一部分，你必须相信他们所相信的。他们想要激进的顺从。互联网上有无数这样的例子。QAnon是一个巨大的例子。没有中央魅力型领袖在举行政治、物理集会
and giving direct daily orders to the masses. Instead, it's such a tight ideology that members collaboratively build the dogma, build the conspiracy theories, decode clues together, and they aggressively excommunicate anyone who has questions, meaning that the conspiracy theory remains solid. There can also be, like, in these decentralized cult situations, kind of a hierarchical structure. There's no one core leader, but there is always somebody above you.
并向大众发出直接的日常命令。相反，这是一种如此紧密的意识形态，成员们协作建立教条，建立阴谋论，一起解码线索，他们积极地将任何有疑问的人逐出教会，这意味着阴谋论保持稳固。在这些去中心化邪教的情况下，也可能存在某种等级结构。没有一个核心领袖，但总有人在你之上。
And even the person at the top, there's somebody above them. And that extreme pressure of, like, who do I trust? Everybody's always watching one another. Authority is flowing in every single direction is powerful enough to mean that you don't need somebody as a central command. I think at its core, the danger of any cult lies with this, with this systematic stripping of critical thinking and personal autonomy. You cannot think for yourself anymore. You think only the way the cult wants you to. So again, this is the question that comes up. Why? Why do people join this? Like, why do they end up in these
即使是处于顶端的人，也有人在他们之上。那种谁值得信任的极端压力？每个人都在一直看着彼此。权威向每一个方向流动，强大到意味着你不需要某人作为中央指挥。我认为在核心，任何邪教的危险在于这个，在于这种对批判性思维和个人自主权的系统性剥夺。你不能再为自己思考了。你只以邪教希望你的方式思考。所以再次，这是出现的问题。为什么？为什么人们加入这个？就像，为什么他们最终进入这些
situations. I think I have a lot of empathy. I think that you can't really understand how compelling the situation must be until you've been through it. I think this is the same line of questioning that comes up when people are like, why don't you leave an abusive relationship or a bad friendship or a bad job? What is underlying this desire to join and this desire to stay is deeply, deeply human. Number one, the reason that people often join cults is because they have a need to belong. In 1995, there were these two researchers, Roy Boymister and Mark Leary. We've talked about them before. And they basically presented this now very incredibly famous paper that said, needing to feel seen and cared for is as essential to our survival as humans as the need
情况。我认为我很有同理心。我认为在你亲身经历之前，你无法真正理解这种情况有多么令人难以抗拒。我认为这和人们问的问题是一样的，比如，为什么你不离开一段虐待关系、一段糟糕的友谊或一份糟糕的工作？这种加入和留下的欲望背后，是极其深刻的人性。第一，人们经常加入邪教的原因是他们有归属感的需求。1995年，有两位研究人员，罗伊·鲍迈斯特（Roy Baumeister）和马克·利里（Mark Leary）。我们之前谈到过他们。他们基本上提出了这篇现在非常出名的论文，指出：需要感到被看见和被关怀，对我们人类的生存而言，就像对食物、水和住所的需求一样重要。
for food, water and shelter. It has the same gravitational pool. Colts, offer to fulfill this innate desire to an extreme. It provides members with a tight-knit community. They are dedicated to one another. They are dedicated to a cause. They offer the promise that you're never going to be alone again. You're never going to be alone. As long as you follow some simple rules, you will always have family, you will always have friends, you will always have somebody who cares about you. When someone feels socially adrift or very isolated, they become a perfect candidate in that moment. Research conducted in 2017 by a group of experts in France actually found that a big number of people who join cults are in periods of major life transition. So they're transitioning into adulthood.
它具有同样的引力。邪教承诺将这种与生俱来的欲望发挥到极致。它为成员提供了一个紧密的社区。他们彼此奉献。他们致力于一项事业。他们承诺你永远不会再孤单。你永远不会孤单。只要你遵守一些简单的规则，你就永远有家人，永远有朋友，永远有关心你的人。当一个人感到社交漂泊或非常孤立时，在那一刻，他们就成了完美的候选人。法国一组专家在2017年进行的研究实际上发现，大量加入邪教的人正处于重大的人生过渡期。所以他们正在过渡到成年。
They're transitioning out of foster care. They're transitioning out of a relationship into retirement. They often have an eroded social system because of this transition they're going through. Those who are susceptible to cult recruitment might also be running away from someone. something, an unhappy life situation, addiction, abuse, a bad relationship, pressure to behave a certain way that they don't agree with, can no longer agree with. In some ways, it makes a lot of logical sense that that would leave them vulnerable to this situation, especially if you've gone through abuse.
他们正在过渡出寄养家庭。他们正在从一段关系过渡到退休。由于他们正在经历的这种过渡，他们的社会支持系统往往已经遭到侵蚀。那些容易受到邪教招募的人可能也在逃避某人、某事、一种不快乐的生活状况、成瘾、虐待、一段糟糕的关系，或者被迫以某种他们不同意、也无法再同意的方式行事。在某种程度上，这在逻辑上是非常合理的，即这会使他们在这种情况下变得脆弱，特别是如果你经历过虐待的话。
You know, someone who has consistently suffered through things like psychological or physical or a mental abuse. A, they would be looking for an escape, but B, they would also be more vulnerable to some of the same practices of love bombing and fear that a cult uses because it feels normal and familiar. Like, they don't see red flags like you or I would because they've only ever known red flags. Many cults are also tied to a spiritual ideology as we spoke about, so a higher power, a God, something that will explain why the world is as ugly and confusing as it is, whether it's lizards or, I don't know, whatever. This is immensely appealing.
你知道，一个长期遭受心理、身体或精神虐待的人。A，他们会寻找逃避的方式，但B，他们也会更容易受到邪教所使用的“爱轰炸”和恐惧等手段的影响，因为这感觉很正常且熟悉。就像，他们不像你或我那样能看到危险信号，因为他们只见过危险信号。正如我们所说，许多邪教也与某种精神意识形态挂钩，所以有一个更高的力量，一个上帝，某种能解释为什么世界如此丑陋和混乱的东西，无论是蜥蜴人，还是，我不知道，随便什么。这非常有吸引力。
Even if we can rationally say that doesn't make any sense, if you are seriously at a low point in your life and you've experienced maybe a crisis of faith in your previous religion or you don't know what the future holds or you are so lost in the world, having a spiritual belief system delivered to you that feels very compelling and a social structure that is built around that, like that sounds like an amazing deal and only a little bit of it has to actually make sense if you are in a really dark place for you to just really want anything to hold on to.
即使我们可以理性地说这毫无意义，但如果你正处于人生的低谷，并且可能在之前的宗教信仰中经历过信仰危机，或者你不知道未来会怎样，或者你在世界上感到非常迷茫，那么有人为你提供一套感觉非常有说服力的精神信仰体系，以及围绕它建立的社会结构，这听起来就像是一笔很棒的交易。如果你正处于一个非常黑暗的地方，只需要其中一小部分听起来有道理，你就会真的想要抓住任何东西。
There is this stereotype that the only people who join cults are unintelligent, they lack thinking skills, they're not very practical, maybe they're dumb, and that creates a lot of shame. It's actually one of the reasons why people don't leave because they know that they're going to be faced with this wall of like, how could you not know? You should have known better. The thing is, cults and coercive groups do not rely on stupidity. They rely on emotional needs. And they rely on a very well-versed knowledge of human psychology. In fact, someone being intelligent is an asset they may be more likely to be targeted. It's an asset to that cult because somebody who is smart will then be in turn, you know, very adept at recruiting more people. They're very good at engaging
有一种刻板印象认为，加入邪教的唯一人选是那些不聪明、缺乏思考能力、不太务实、甚至愚蠢的人，这造成了很大的羞耻感。这实际上是人们不离开的原因之一，因为他们知道自己将面临这样的指责：“你怎么会不知道？你应该更聪明一点的。”问题是，邪教和强制性团体并不依赖愚蠢。它们依赖的是情感需求。它们依赖于对人类心理非常精通的知识。事实上，一个人聪明反而是一种资产，他们可能更容易成为目标。这对邪教来说是一种资产，因为聪明的人反过来会非常擅长招募更多的人。他们非常擅长参与
manipulation tactics. They're very good at evading authorities. They become helpful and desirable. There's something else going on as well in this situation. And it has to do with the very same dopamine systems that explain why we get hooked on drugs, why we get hooked on gambling, on food, on nicotine. It is this addiction model that may explain why seemingly normal people end up in these situations. We're going to talk about it after this short break. If anyone wanted to commit a murder, up here would be the greatest place in the world
操纵策略。他们非常擅长逃避当局。他们变得乐于助人且令人向往。在这种情况下，还有其他事情在发生。这与解释为什么我们对毒品、赌博、食物、尼古丁上瘾的同一个多巴胺系统有关。正是这种成瘾模型可能解释了为什么看似正常的人最终会陷入这些境地。我们将在短暂休息后讨论这个问题。如果有人想谋杀，这里将是世界上隐藏尸体的最佳地点
to hide the body. But no one will find it. He acted friendly. He talked friendly. He sounded friendly. They all knew that I did the scary boogie stuff. And they said, maybe she'll find out where this girl is. I saw him violent.
没人会找到它。他表现得很友好。他说话很友好。他听起来很友好。他们都知道我做过那些可怕的勾当。他们说，也许她会发现这个女孩在哪里。我看到他很暴力。
Backhanded her, pow! And that's exactly what made us all think he had something to do with him. The clock is ticking down and the woods are calling. There are a lot of demons in Putnam County. But I've met the devil, and he's real. I'm Paul Solitarev, and this is season two of the devil's quarry. Listen to The Devil's Quarry Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear The Devil's Quarry Season 2 ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Lava for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts.
反手给了她一巴掌，砰！这正是让我们所有人都认为他与她有关的原因。时钟在倒计时，森林在呼唤。普特南县有很多恶魔。但我见过魔鬼，他是真实的。我是保罗·索利塔列夫（Paul Solitarev），这是《魔鬼采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）第二季。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《魔鬼采石场》第二季。要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《魔鬼采石场》第二季，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Lava for Good Plus。
Hey everybody, it's me, W. Comaubel Bell. This season of my podcast who's with me, I speak with two-time Emmy winner and weirdly one of my best friends, Kevin Avery. Everything up to that point Build you as a comic Us going on the road Doing Battle Mountain and Ely Yeah, you took me You were one of the first people
大家好，我是W.卡茂贝尔（W. Kamau Bell）。这一季我的播客《谁和我在一起》（Who's With Me），我采访了两次艾美奖得主，也是我最好的朋友之一，凯文·艾弗里（Kevin Avery）。在那之前的一切都把你塑造成一个喜剧演员，我们一起去巡演，去了巴特尔山（Battle Mountain）和伊利（Ely）。是的，你带了我，你是第一批
Took me on the road Which is funny because at the time I was like I don't know if I like this guy With rapper, actor, David Diggs The jump off for me was Hamilton And it was the most popular thing
带我上路的人之一。这很有趣，因为当时我在想，我不知道我是否喜欢这个家伙。和说唱歌手、演员戴维德·迪格斯（Daveed Diggs）。对我来说，跳板是《汉密尔顿》（Hamilton），它是最受欢迎的东西
In a very long time But it was still for me It was me and my friends Making something dumb Bruce Lee's daughter And Brandon Lee's sister Shannon Lee Back to your initial point of stewarding my father's legacy and giving my energy to that.
在很长一段时间里。但对我来说，那仍然是我和我的朋友们在做一些愚蠢的事情。李小龙的女儿和李国豪的妹妹香农·李（Shannon Lee）。回到你最初关于管理我父亲遗产并为此投入精力的观点。
You're lending your life to stewarding somebody else's life. Listen to Who's With Me with with Debbie Kumal on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal, we meet Carl Bryant. Carl thought he was living a normal drama-free life until the messages started. You will have hell to pay.
你把你的生命借给了管理别人的生命。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听黛比·库马贝尔（Debbie Kumabelle）的《谁和我在一起》。你毁了我。你不配拥有幸福。我是安德里亚·甘宁（Andrea Gunning）。在这一季的《背叛》（Betrayal）中，我们遇到了卡尔·布莱恩特（Carl Bryant）。卡尔以为他过着正常、无忧无虑的生活，直到那些信息开始出现。你会付出代价的。
For nine months, someone infiltrated every aspect of Carl's life threatening to ruin him. Cyberstalking, swatting, extortion, impersonation. And then the text threats escalated. Someone's not going to make it out of this alive. This department. It's playing out in real life, not just on the phone. Every piece of evidence pointed to one man. But every piece of evidence was a lie.
九个月来，有人渗透到卡尔生活的方方面面，威胁要毁掉他。网络跟踪、虚假报警、勒索、冒充。然后短信威胁升级了。有人不会活着离开这里。这个部门。它在现实生活中上演，不仅仅是在电话里。每一条证据都指向一个人。但每一条证据都是谎言。
He was not going to stop unless we stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's. Health and Gynecology at the Adria Health Institute in New York City. On this show, I'll be talking to top researchers and top clinicians asking them your burning questions and bringing that information about women's health and midlife directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. It can be such a struggle for our quality of life, but even if it's natural, why should
除非我们阻止他，否则他不会停止。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《背叛》第六季。欢迎来到《解码女性健康》（Decoding Women's Health）。我是伊丽莎白·波因特（Elizabeth Pointer）博士，纽约市阿德里亚健康研究所（Adria Health Institute）女性健康与妇科系主任。在这个节目中，我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，询问你们最关心的问题，并将有关女性健康和中年期的信息直接带给你们。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。这可能会对我们的生活质量造成很大困扰，但即使它是自然的，为什么我们
we suffer through it? The types of symptoms that people talk about is forgetting everything. I never used to forget things. They're concerned that, one, they have dementia, and the other one is, do I have ADHD? There is unprecedented promise with regard to cannabis and cannabinoids, to sleep better, to have less pain, to have better mood, and also to have better day-to-day life. Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you're listening now. I'm former U.S. Women's National Soccer team player, Carly Lloyd. I'm Fox Sports Reporter Jenny Taft, And on our new podcast, whatever it takes,
要忍受它呢？人们谈论的症状类型是忘记一切。我以前从不忘记事情。他们担心，第一，他们患有痴呆症，第二，我有ADHD吗？大麻和大麻素在改善睡眠、减轻疼痛、改善情绪以及改善日常生活中有着前所未有的前景。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你现在收听的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·波因特博士的《解码女性健康》。我是前美国国家女子足球队队员卡莉·劳埃德（Carly Lloyd）。我是福克斯体育记者珍妮·塔夫脱（Jenny Taft），在我们的新播客《不惜一切代价》（Whatever It Takes）中，
we're talking motherhood, marriages, careers, and figuring out how to balance it all. And we'll discuss the game that brought us together because nothing is off limits. Do you remember your initial reaction when Fox called you to be a part of the World Cup? I was like, no, I don't want to do it. You said no?
我们谈论母性、婚姻、事业，并弄清楚如何平衡这一切。我们将讨论让我们走到一起的那场比赛，因为没有什么是不可以谈论的。你还记得福克斯打电话让你参加世界杯时的最初反应吗？我说，不，我不想做。你说不？
I played with players that didn't, I don't think that they really, truly love the game. I found the love with the ball at my foot. But in my head, it was the long. long game. It was like, I don't care what I'm being asked to do at Fox. I'm going to go get some reps and I'm going to learn it and love it and embrace it. He said, this group of people will never be in the same room as part of the same team ever again in your life. And it is your job to make sure that you enjoy the moment. You're proud of what you accomplish together. Listen to whatever it
我和那些我不认为他们真正热爱这项运动的球员一起踢球。我在脚下有球时找到了爱。但在我的脑海里，这是一场漫长的比赛。就像，我不在乎福克斯要求我做什么。我要去获得一些经验，我要学习它、热爱它并拥抱它。他说，这群人这辈子再也不会作为同一个团队的一部分出现在同一个房间里了。你的工作是确保你享受这一刻。你为你共同取得的成就感到自豪。收听《不惜一切代价》
takes with Carly Lloyd and Jenny Taft on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So something, as I hinted to, that's being increasingly discussed in the cult psychology space is this idea that those people who join cults may actually be experiencing a form of human or relational addiction. And they may have been more susceptible to addictive patterns or addictive habits in the past or in the first place. There was a study from 2017 and interviewed 31 former cult members in Sweden, and it discovered that a lot of them were displaying behaviors that match what we call Goodman's Addictive Disorders Criteria. The Goodman's Criteria is a very common tool used in psychology to identify whether somebody is in active addiction. They can be
与卡莉·劳埃德和珍妮·塔夫脱一起，在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。所以，正如我所暗示的，在邪教心理学领域越来越多地讨论的一个观点是，那些加入邪教的人可能实际上正在经历一种形式的人类或关系成瘾。他们过去可能更容易受到成瘾模式或成瘾习惯的影响。2017年有一项研究采访了瑞典的31名前邪教成员，发现他们中的许多人表现出的行为符合我们所说的古德曼成瘾障碍标准（Goodman's Addictive Disorders Criteria）。古德曼标准是心理学中用来识别某人是否处于活跃成瘾状态的非常常见的工具。他们可以
addicted to anything. It's used for alcohol, it's used for food, sex, social media. People can also be addicted to the behaviors and the feelings of others and the behavior and feeling of being in a cult. That is what this research has started to show. For example, here are some of the criteria for being in a state of addiction according to this model. A, you feel that you may lack control. You may feel a sense of relief when you encounter the stimulus or you participate in the activity or the cult. You may have an inability to resist the thing and increasing tolerance for the thing, become more accustomed to a certain level of the feeling or the behavior and it affects you less and less. A great deal of time is spent with the thing that you're addicted to. It's difficult
对任何事情上瘾。它适用于酒精、食物、性、社交媒体。人们也可以对他人以及身处邪教的行为和感觉上瘾。这就是这项研究开始显示的内容。例如，根据这个模型，以下是处于成瘾状态的一些标准。A，你觉得你可能缺乏控制力。当你遇到刺激或参与活动或邪教时，你可能会感到一种解脱感。你可能无法抗拒某件事，并且对某件事的耐受力增加，变得越来越习惯于某种程度的感觉或行为，而它对你的影响越来越小。大量时间花在你上瘾的事情上。很难
to cut out the thing that you're addicted to. It's difficult to think about anything other than the thing you are addicted to. Replace thing with cults. The same neurological systems that drive cravings and intense desires are working in this situation. In fact, a lot of those individuals who we were speaking about initially actually reported having some other kind of addiction or some addiction in their past, whether it's too alcohol or gambling. And the research has basically suggested that when they joined the cult, they replaced the substance addiction with an addiction to the system. A switch was made. This is a critical part of this research. These people were already neurologically, some would say biologically and definitely psychologically vulnerable.
戒掉你上瘾的东西。很难思考除了你上瘾的东西以外的任何事情。用“邪教”代替“东西”。驱动渴望和强烈欲望的同一个神经系统在这种情况下也在起作用。事实上，我们最初谈到的许多人实际上报告说过去有某种其他类型的成瘾，无论是酒精还是赌博。研究基本上表明，当他们加入邪教时，他们用对系统的成瘾取代了物质成瘾。发生了一个转换。这是这项研究的关键部分。这些人已经在神经学上，有些人会说是生物学上，绝对是心理学上很脆弱。
for something to come in and provide them with the relief that maybe alcohol or gambling or a substance had done in the past. And it felt a lot healthier because it felt like connection. This is a critical part. I keep saying that, but this is a critical part of this research. There was an incredibly high prevalence and there is an incredibly high prevalence of psychiatric conditions in people prior to joining cults. A lot of people over half from this study suffered from anxiety disorders and mood disorders in the lead up to when they joined. And interestingly, the majority of participants reported at first feeling better,
等待某种东西进来，为他们提供酒精、赌博或物质过去可能提供的解脱。而且它感觉健康得多，因为它感觉像是连接。这是一个关键部分。我一直在说，但这确实是这项研究的关键部分。在加入邪教之前，人们患有精神疾病的比例非常高。在这项研究中，超过一半的人在加入之前患有焦虑症和情绪障碍。有趣的是，大多数参与者报告说起初感觉更好，
feeling psychological relief when they first got involved with their cult. Their symptoms of anxiety and depression and distress reduced. the same way that when you first take alcohol or painkillers, your feelings of depression and anxiety reduce. It feels like your savior. It feels like you found a thing that's going to give you a center until you need more and more of it to feel good and until it really becomes the center of your world and until it starts ruining your life. That is the cult addiction pathway. I really want to emphasize something here. It is actually not as rare as you think for someone. to be in a cult or to have encountered a cult or to have at least felt some kind of pull towards
当他们第一次接触邪教时，感到心理上的解脱。他们的焦虑、抑郁和痛苦症状减轻了。就像你第一次服用酒精或止痛药时，你的抑郁和焦虑感会减轻一样。它感觉像是你的救星。它感觉像是你找到了一个能给你中心的东西，直到你需要越来越多它来感觉良好，直到它真正成为你世界的中心，直到它开始毁掉你的生活。这就是邪教成瘾路径。我真的想在这里强调一点。一个人身处邪教，或遇到过邪教，或至少感受到某种对
this system. There is this man, he's since passed, but his name was Arthur Dekeman, I think, Dyckman, Dickman. He was a professor of psychiatry at the University of California. And he did a lot of work around cults and around social belonging, asking this same question we're asking today, what drives people to perform this social behavior? And in the this quest for answers, he conducted this series of seminars. Maybe it's like, I guess, a meeting. He just invited a bunch of former cult members in the 90s to this big conference and he spoke to them. And what he said and his report on it was, these people are so normal. They are so normal. And he also said a lot of their experiences in joining a cult are very similar to everyday experiences
这个系统的吸引力，其实并不像你想象的那么罕见。有个人，他已经去世了，但他的名字叫亚瑟·迪克曼（Arthur Deikman）。他是加州大学的精神病学教授。他围绕邪教和社交归属感做了大量工作，问了我们今天问的同一个问题：是什么驱动人们表现出这种社会行为？在寻找答案的过程中，他进行了一系列研讨会。也许就像，我猜，一次会议。他在90年代邀请了一群前邪教成员参加这个大型会议，并与他们交谈。他说的话以及他关于此的报告是：这些人太正常了。他们太正常了。他还说，他们加入邪教的许多经历与我们在工作、政治、人际关系和传统宗教中的日常经历非常相似，
that we would have in work, in politics, in relationships and in traditional religions, which made it hard for them to tell that something bad was going on. Deekman had this one sentence that I think really gripped people. He said, people join cults not because they are crazy, but because they have two kinds of wishes. They want a meaningful life and they want to feel taken care of and protected. Those are the two reasons people join cults. If you think about it, this is the exact same reason we pursue certain careers. We want meaning. We want to feel taken care of. It's the same reason. It's the same reason we vote for certain political parties, why we date certain people, why we choose a certain lifestyle, why we choose a certain diet, why we choose certain friends. Even where we get things like
这使得他们很难分辨出有什么坏事正在发生。迪克曼有一句话，我认为真的抓住了人们的心。他说，人们加入邪教不是因为他们疯了，而是因为他们有两种愿望。他们想要有意义的生活，他们想要感到被照顾和保护。这就是人们加入邪教的两个原因。如果你仔细想想，这正是我们追求某些职业的相同原因。我们想要意义。我们想要感到被照顾。这是同样的原因。这也是我们投票给某些政党、为什么我们和某些人约会、为什么我们选择某种生活方式、为什么我们选择某种饮食、为什么我们选择某些朋友的相同原因。甚至我们得到像
plastic surgery, like we think it will make our life more meaningful, we think it will make our life happier because we will achieve greater acceptance. Everything and anything can be a cult. If the marketing is good enough and the manipulation is there and the community is strong, even certain brands, certain diets, certain movements, you know, like we said, Disney adults, like it's not a cult, it definitely could become one. If they found a charismatic leader who wanted to do harm, that is literally like so many of the systems that we have are just not being manipulated and therefore don't get the cult name. So with that in mind, if that's why people join them for these very human reasons, why don't people leave once they realize something is going wrong?
整形手术这样的东西，我们认为它会让我们的生活更有意义，我们认为它会让我们的生活更快乐，因为我们将获得更大的认可。任何事情都可以成为邪教。如果营销足够好，操纵存在，社区足够强大，甚至某些品牌、某些饮食、某些运动，你知道，就像我们说的，迪士尼成年人，它不是邪教，它绝对可能变成一个。如果他们找到了一个想要作恶的魅力型领导者，这实际上就像我们拥有的许多系统一样，只是没有被操纵，因此没有得到邪教的名字。所以考虑到这一点，如果这就是人们出于这些非常人性化的原因加入它们，为什么人们在意识到事情出错后不离开呢？
as we've realized people join cults for the belonging and for the love and for the meaning and they stay in cults because of the isolation and the fear and the cost of leaving. In that same study, the one from 2017 with the 31 former cult members, these same people, they were asked why did you join and they were asked why didn't you leave? And the biggest thing they said was my whole life was there. I had given it everything. These people were my family. If I left, like, I would have nothing.
正如我们所意识到的，人们加入邪教是为了归属感、爱和意义，而他们留在邪教是因为孤立、恐惧和离开的代价。在同一项研究中，即2017年对31名前邪教成员的研究中，这些人被问到为什么加入，也被问到为什么不离开？他们说的最大的一点是：我的整个人生都在那里。我已经付出了一切。这些人是我的家人。如果我离开，就像，我将一无所有。
It is the sunk cost fallacy that we all experience on a whole new scale. Of course, yes, there's the relationships that people are losing, which directly contradicts that human need to belong. So it's going to feel painful. It's going to act as a motivational force to stay. But there's also practical things like, money. People in serious cults often haven't had a job in the real world for a long time. All their finances are wrapped up in the cult. They have been asked to invest all their money
这就是我们都经历过的沉没成本谬误，但在一个全新的规模上。当然，是的，人们正在失去人际关系，这直接违背了人类归属的需要。所以这会让人感到痛苦。它将作为一种留下的动力。但也有实际的事情，比如金钱。在严重邪教中的人通常很长一段时间没有在现实世界中工作。他们所有的财务都卷入了邪教。他们被要求投资他们所有的钱
to sign away the deeds to their house, the deeds to their future earnings. Somebody might say, why don't they just go to the police? Why don't they go to charity? Why don't they go to government services for help? You know, yeah, it's the practical concerns. They may not have their birth certificate, their passport. They may not literally have public transport to leave the physical location. And then there's the most important element of all. As much as they fear the cult and they fear what's happening, they fear what's beyond and the unknown even more. Many people are initially, as we said, attracted to cults because, you know, they're scared, they're vulnerable, they believe the wider world to be bad or to be confusing.
签署放弃他们房子的契约，他们未来收入的契约。有人可能会问，为什么他们不直接去警察局？为什么他们不去慈善机构？为什么他们不去政府部门寻求帮助？你知道，是的，这是实际的担忧。他们可能没有出生证明、护照。他们可能实际上没有公共交通工具离开物理位置。然后还有最重要的一点。尽管他们害怕邪教，害怕正在发生的事情，但他们更害怕超越和未知。正如我们所说，许多人最初被邪教吸引是因为，你知道，他们害怕，他们脆弱，他们认为更广阔的世界是坏的或令人困惑的。
cults then magnify this and indoctrinate their followers to further that sense of evil. They want them to believe this is the only place you are safe, this is a sanctuary, you have to stay here, if you were to leave, terrible things would happen to you. And if you say that to somebody enough times, they believe it. I read this interview with a woman who left like a very isolated cult in Australia, and she said she truly believed that people outside the cult would kill her, eat her and poison her. She was born into the cult, like her mother had joined as a single mother, and how would she know that wasn't true? Like, she'd never met an outsider.
邪教随后放大了这一点，并向他们的追随者灌输以加深那种邪恶感。他们希望他们相信这是你唯一安全的地方，这是一个避难所，你必须留在这里，如果你离开，可怕的事情会发生在你身上。如果你对某人说足够多次，他们就会相信。我读过一篇对一位离开澳大利亚一个非常孤立的邪教的女性的采访，她说她真的相信邪教外的人会杀了她、吃了她并毒死她。她是出生在邪教里的，就像她母亲作为单身母亲加入的那样，她怎么会知道那不是真的呢？就像，她从未见过外人。
She had no alternative evidence to what she'd been told. It is like you or I trying to imagine a color that we haven't seen before. If you have net, you just can't. She could not fathom that other people would feel safe. There was another person, I think it was in the same article, who escaped a cult in South Korea, and they did this interview with The Guardian. in. He was like, I genuinely believed the cult leader could hear my thoughts. So I couldn't even think, I was so indoctrinated. The thought of leaving didn't even enter my mind because it felt so blasphemous and dangerous. His brain was trained into avoiding the very idea of leaving itself. It's here
她没有被告知的替代证据。这就像你或我试图想象一种我们以前没见过的颜色。如果你没有，你就是做不到。她无法想象其他人会感到安全。还有另一个人，我想是在同一篇文章中，他逃离了韩国的一个邪教，他们接受了《卫报》的采访。他说，我真诚地相信邪教领袖能听到我的想法。所以我甚至不能思考，我被灌输得太深了。离开的想法甚至没有进入我的脑海，因为它感觉太亵渎和危险了。他的大脑被训练成避免离开这个想法本身。就在这里
where we have to talk about the psychology of Stockholm syndrome, right? Feeling like the only safe thing is the thing that's hurting you. Some shameless self-promotion here. We did recently do a full bonus episode on this. It's not on Netflix. It's only on Spotify. We did it a month or so back. It's like a full history of Stockholm Syndrome. It's very fascinating. So if you liked this episode, you'll probably love that one. And it's the reason why I'm not getting fully into this. But Stockholm Syndrome definitely applies in cult situations, probably more than anything else, which we explored in that episode. A brief overview, Stockholm Syndrome was a term that was born from a hostage situation in Sweden in 1973. And in this situation, it was very strange. These hostages
我们必须谈谈斯德哥尔摩综合症的心理学，对吧？感觉唯一安全的东西就是伤害你的东西。这里做一点无耻的自我推销。我们最近确实做了一期关于这个的完整奖励剧集。它不在Netflix上。它只在Spotify上。我们在一个月前左右做的。它就像斯德哥尔摩综合症的完整历史。它非常迷人。所以如果你喜欢这一集，你可能会喜欢那一集。这就是我没有完全深入探讨的原因。但斯德哥尔摩综合症绝对适用于邪教情况，可能比任何其他情况都适用，我们在那一集中探讨过。简要概述，斯德哥尔摩综合症是一个源于1973年瑞典人质事件的术语。在这种情况下，非常奇怪。这些人质
developed deep empathy for their captors. They even defended them in the aftermath. And everybody in the news, all these rescuers were like, that is so unnatural. How could you feel any form of love or empathy for somebody who has harmed you? It has since become, we know it's a psychological phenomena. And we know what it derives from is the fact that humans will do anything to survive. and to adapt under extreme pressure. And if the only way for them to do that is to form a connection or an attachment with the very people who are going to harm them, if that's their only avenue to safety, they will do that.
对他们的绑架者产生了深深的同理心。他们甚至在事后为他们辩护。新闻里的每个人，所有这些救援人员都说，这太不自然了。你怎么能对伤害过你的人产生任何形式的爱或同理心？它后来成为，我们知道这是一种心理现象。我们知道它源于这样一个事实：人类会做任何事情来生存，并在极端压力下适应。如果他们这样做的唯一方法是与那些将要伤害他们的人形成联系或依恋，如果那是他们获得安全的唯一途径，他们就会这样做。
In a cult setting, like so many parallels, so many parallels to that hostage kind of situation. Firstly, as a follower, you are probably experiencing small acts of kindness that convince you that it can't be that bad. your needs are probably taken care of. That creates a whole other layer of dependency. And so you're scared. You feel like your freedom is being curtailed,
在邪教环境中，有太多的相似之处，与那种人质情况有太多的相似之处。首先，作为追随者，你可能正在经历一些小小的善举，让你相信它不会那么糟糕。你的需求可能得到了满足。这创造了另一层依赖。所以你很害怕。你觉得你的自由受到了限制，
but you also feel grateful. Your basic needs are being taken care of. And that is difficult to abandon. It's difficult to feel like, wait, something that wants to harm me probably wouldn't take care of me as well. And this creates a sense that they are indebted. They should be grateful. even as their other needs, like perhaps don't feel fulfilled, their primary needs are.
但你也感到感激。你的基本需求得到了满足。这很难放弃。很难觉得，等等，想要伤害我的东西可能不会也照顾我。这创造了一种他们负债的感觉。他们应该心存感激。即使他们的其他需求，比如可能感觉没有得到满足，他们的主要需求得到了满足。
Like with Stockholm Syndrome as well, cult followers may also identify with the aggressor or the cult leader. Like, there might be some similarities. Like, they joined the cult for a reason. Obviously, there is some kind of shared vision or shared values that lines up. So it becomes hard to disentangle oneself, the same way someone may see themselves. in a captor or in a Stockholm syndrome situation because they need to see them as like them so they can understand them and survive. Of course, when people are in a violent situation, like in Sweden in
就像斯德哥尔摩综合症一样，邪教追随者也可能认同侵略者或邪教领袖。就像，可能有一些相似之处。就像，他们加入邪教是有原因的。显然，有一些共同的愿景或共同的价值观是一致的。所以很难将自己解脱出来，就像某人可能在绑架者或斯德哥尔摩综合症情况下看到自己一样，因为他们需要把他们看作像他们一样，这样他们才能理解他们并生存下去。当然，当人们处于暴力情况下时，就像在瑞典
1973, outsiders can clearly see that something is wrong and they can intervene. But when it comes to removing someone from a cult situation that they may be choosing to be in, like things get very complicated. So when somebody does manage to leave a cult, like how do they feel afterwards? That's the natural next step, right? It's going to feel like, of course, like every human experience very different. But from what I've read, it's deeply traumatic, even if they know it's the right choice. I think the biggest way it's going to differ from person to person is whether someone chose to exit the cult willingly, whether they were subject to some kind of involuntary reprogramming, or whether the cult kind of imploded in on itself and in on them. And there are
1973年，局外人可以清楚地看到出了问题，他们可以干预。但当涉及到将某人从他们可能选择身处的邪教情况中移除时，事情就变得非常复杂。所以当某人确实设法离开邪教时，他们事后感觉如何？那是自然的下一步，对吧？感觉就像，当然，像每一种人类体验一样非常不同。但据我所读，这是极其痛苦的，即使他们知道这是正确的选择。我认为它因人而异的最大区别在于某人是自愿选择退出邪教，还是受到某种非自愿的重新编程，或者邪教是否在自身内部崩溃了。并且有
many examples of this happening. There was this cult in Oregon in the 80s. Money and taxes comes into this a lot more than you think. And this cult was, I can't remember what it was called, but it was basically the huge utopia in the middle of the desert. And it fell apart like overnight because of a federal investigation into money laundering. And here are these people who joined not for money for religious reasons. And they were basically all flung back into the world completely unprepared. Like they really, they'd been there for a while. they had to adjust overnight. A study from 2023 looked at former cult members' experiences of leaving, and what they found was this in-between stage. They've just exited the cults, but they're not yet fully
很多这样的例子。80年代在俄勒冈州有一个邪教。金钱和税收比你想象的更多地涉及其中。这个邪教是，我不记得它叫什么了，但它基本上是沙漠中间的巨大乌托邦。它因为联邦对洗钱的调查而在一夜之间分崩离析。这里有这些人，他们加入不是为了钱，而是为了宗教原因。他们基本上都被完全没有准备地扔回了世界。就像他们真的，他们在那里待了一段时间。他们必须在一夜之间调整。2023年的一项研究观察了前邪教成员离开的经历，他们发现的是这个中间阶段。他们刚刚退出了邪教，但还没有完全
integrated back into society. And in this study, they closely examined 11 individuals who were going through this, who had cult experiences and who had left, and they found that almost all of them described a state of internal psychological chaos immediately after leaving where they were like, I don't know if I've made the right choice and I feel worse than I ever have before. In this study, the former cult members described having a lot of them had lived in this like honor culture where acts of violence were very normalized and that itself required a lot of deprogramming and processing because A, like they rejoined society and they had to know you can't this eye for the eye justice doesn't work here. It's not tolerated.
融入社会。在这项研究中，他们密切检查了11个正在经历这一过程的个人，他们有邪教经历并且已经离开，他们发现几乎所有人都描述了离开后立即出现的内部心理混乱状态，他们就像，我不知道我是否做出了正确的选择，我感觉比以往任何时候都更糟。在这项研究中，前邪教成员描述了他们中的许多人生活在这种荣誉文化中，暴力行为非常正常化，这本身就需要大量的重新编程和处理，因为A，他们重新加入了社会，他们必须知道你不能，这种以眼还眼的公正在这里行不通。它不被容忍。
B, they had to be okay and know that that wasn't going to happen to them. They were very scared of breaking rules and somebody, you know, doing something to them. The participants also described something that I found so interesting, which is that in the cult, everything was made sense for them. Like they could rely on the cult for meaning, for order, for their daily routines. And then they lost that structure and that made them feel very depressed, very hopeless. They had this, it was a spiritual crisis, it's a social crisis and then it's a physical crisis of like, what do I do with my days and what do I believe in? It's interesting because some researchers are very quick to say that people think entering a cult is the hardest and most disruptive part
B，他们必须没问题，并且知道那不会发生在他们身上。他们非常害怕打破规则，有人，你知道，对他们做些什么。参与者还描述了一些我发现非常有趣的事情，那就是在邪教中，一切都为他们做好了意义。就像他们可以依靠邪教来获得意义、秩序、他们的日常惯例。然后他们失去了那种结构，这让他们感到非常沮丧，非常绝望。他们有这个，这是一场精神危机，这是一场社会危机，然后是一场身体危机，比如，我该怎么度过我的日子，我相信什么？这很有趣，因为一些研究人员很快就说，人们认为进入邪教是最困难和最具破坏性的部分
of this whole process. And it's not. It's the six months after leaving where someone has to process everything that's happened to them. And they are also, probably a little part of them is still mourning the good stuff and still mourning the relationship, I guess. As I said in the intro, all of this is important to know because cult are on the rise. They are increasing significantly if you look at the data. Because the world is becoming more unstable, during times like this, more people will go out looking for an ideological center. And in the current climate we're in, misinformation and that
在整个过程中。事实并非如此。离开后的六个月，某人必须处理发生在他们身上的一切。而且他们也可能，他们内心的一小部分仍然在为好的东西哀悼，仍然在为那段关系哀悼，我想。正如我在介绍中所说，所有这些都是重要的知识，因为邪教正在兴起。如果你看数据，它们正在显著增加。因为世界变得越来越不稳定，在这样的时期，更多的人会出去寻找一个意识形态中心。在我们所处的当前气候下，错误信息和那种
ideological misinformation reaches them a lot quicker. I think we're going to be seeing more and more of this deprogramming happening for more and more people who seem relatively normal. Colts are on the rise, literally in this research, I was like, I was like, I'm going to see if I can find a cult. I'm just going to see what I can find. I found three active cults with Instagram pages and TikTok accounts. One of them has. young members posting lifestyle content. And that is content that you or I could very easily consume and could very easily encounter. That is a cult recruiting through TikTok. So what are some of the new age cults that we need to be on the lookout for? I'm talking about cults that may not
意识形态错误信息更快地传达到他们。我认为我们将看到越来越多的这种重新编程发生在越来越多看起来相对正常的人身上。邪教正在兴起，实际上在这项研究中，我当时想，我要看看我是否能找到一个邪教。我只是要看看我能找到什么。我找到了三个带有Instagram页面和TikTok账户的活跃邪教。其中一个有年轻成员发布生活方式内容。那是你或我可以很容易消费并很容易遇到的内容。那是一个通过TikTok招募的邪教。那么我们需要警惕哪些新时代邪教呢？我说的是那些可能不
look like the Manson Col or the Heavensgate cult or what we have in mind when we think of compounds and secret camps and Kool-Aid. These cults are a lot more sinister. I want to present three of the biggest ones of our day and age. I want to see if you guys ever encountered them. You've definitely encountered at least one. Stay with us. We're going to talk about it right after this short break. If anyone wanted to commit a murder,
看起来像曼森家族（Manson Cult）或天堂之门（Heavensgate）邪教，或者当我们想到大院、秘密营地和毒药时我们脑海中的那种。这些邪教要阴险得多。我想展示我们这个时代最大的三个。我想看看你们是否遇到过它们。你们肯定至少遇到过一个。和我们在一起。我们将在短暂休息后讨论这个问题。如果有人想谋杀，
up here would be the greatest place in the world to hide the body. But no one will find it. He acted friendly. He talked friendly. He sounded friendly. They all knew that I did the scary boogie stuff. And I said, Maybe she'll find out where this girl is.
这里将是世界上隐藏尸体的最佳地点。但没人会找到它。他表现得很友好。他说话很友好。他听起来很友好。他们都知道我做过那些可怕的勾当。我说，也许她会发现这个女孩在哪里。
I saw him violent. Backhanded a bow. And that's exactly what made us all think he had something to do with him. The clock is ticking down and the woods are calling. There are a lot of demons in Putnam County. But I've met the devil and he's real. I'm Paul Solitarov and this is season two of the devil's quarry. Listen to The Devil's Quarry Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我看到他很暴力。反手给了她一巴掌。这正是让我们所有人都认为他与她有关的原因。时钟在倒计时，森林在呼唤。普特南县有很多恶魔。但我见过魔鬼，他是真实的。我是保罗·索利塔列夫，这是《魔鬼采石场》第二季。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《魔鬼采石场》第二季。
And to hear The Devil's Quarry Season 2 add free with exclusive content. Subscribe to Lava for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal, we meet Carl Bryant. Carl thought he was living a normal, drama-free life. until the messages started.
要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《魔鬼采石场》第二季，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Lava for Good Plus。你毁了我。你不配拥有幸福。我是安德里亚·甘宁。在这一季的《背叛》中，我们遇到了卡尔·布莱恩特。卡尔以为他过着正常、无忧无虑的生活，直到那些信息开始出现。
You will have hell to pay. For nine months, someone infiltrated every aspect of Carl's life, threatening to ruin him. Cyberstalking, swatting, extortion, impersonation. And then the text threats escalated. Someone's not going to make it out of this alive. Dance department. It's playing out in real life, not just on the phone. Every piece of evidence pointed to one man.
你会付出代价的。九个月来，有人渗透到卡尔生活的方方面面，威胁要毁掉他。网络跟踪、虚假报警、勒索、冒充。然后短信威胁升级了。有人不会活着离开这里。这个部门。它在现实生活中上演，不仅仅是在电话里。每一条证据都指向一个人。
But every piece of evidence was a lie. He was not going to stop unless we stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, everybody, it's me, W. Compte Bell. This season of my podcast who's with me, I speak with two-time Emmy winner and weirdly one of my best friends, Kevin Avery. Everything up to that point Build you as a comic Us going on the road
但每一条证据都是谎言。除非我们阻止他，否则他不会停止。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《背叛》第六季。大家好，我是W.卡茂贝尔。这一季我的播客《谁和我在一起》，我采访了两次艾美奖得主，也是我最好的朋友之一，凯文·艾弗里。在那之前的一切都把你塑造成一个喜剧演员，我们一起去巡演
Doing Battle Mountain and Ely Yeah you took me You were one of the first people Took me on the road Which is funny because at the time I was like I don't know if I like this guy With rapper Actor David Diggs
去了巴特尔山和伊利。是的，你带了我，你是第一批带我上路的人之一。这很有趣，因为当时我在想，我不知道我是否喜欢这个家伙。和说唱歌手、演员戴维德·迪格斯
The jump off for me was Hamilton And it was the most popular thing in a very long time But it was still for me It was me and my friends Making something dumb Bruce Lee's daughter And Brandon Lee's sister
对我来说，跳板是《汉密尔顿》，它是最受欢迎的东西，在很长一段时间里。但对我来说，那仍然是我和我的朋友们在做一些愚蠢的事情。李小龙的女儿和李国豪的妹妹
Shannon Lee Back to your initial point of stewarding my father's legacy and giving my energy to that, you're lending your life to stewarding somebody else's life. Listen to Who's With Me with me with Debbie Kumabelle on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm former U.S. Women's National Soccer team player, Carly Lloyd. I'm Fox Sports Reporter Jenny Taft. And on our new podcast, whatever it takes, we're talking motherhood, marriages, careers, and figuring. out how to balance it all. And we'll discuss the game that brought us together
香农·李。回到你最初关于管理我父亲遗产并为此投入精力的观点，你把你的生命借给了管理别人的生命。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听黛比·库马贝尔的《谁和我在一起》。我是前美国国家女子足球队队员卡莉·劳埃德。我是福克斯体育记者珍妮·塔夫脱。在我们的新播客《不惜一切代价》中，我们谈论母性、婚姻、事业，并弄清楚如何平衡这一切。我们将讨论让我们走到一起的那场比赛
because nothing is off limits. Do you remember your initial reaction when Fox called you to be a part of the World Cup? I was like, no, I don't want to do it. You said no? I played with players that didn't... I don't think that they really, truly love the game. I found the love with the ball at my foot.
因为没有什么是不可以谈论的。你还记得福克斯打电话让你参加世界杯时的最初反应吗？我说，不，我不想做。你说不？我和那些我不认为他们真正热爱这项运动的球员一起踢球。我在脚下有球时找到了爱。
But in my head, it was the long game. It was like, I don't care what I'm being asked to do at Fox. I'm going to go get some reps. and I'm going to learn it and love it and embrace it. He said, this group of people will never be in the same room as part of the same team ever again in your life. And it is your job to make sure that you enjoy the moment. You're proud of what you accomplish together. Listen to whatever it takes with Carly Lloyd and Jenny Taft on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
但在我脑海里，这是一场持久战。就像是，我不在乎福克斯要求我做什么。我要去多做些练习，我要去学习它、热爱它并拥抱它。他说，这群人这辈子再也不会作为同一个团队出现在同一个房间里了。你的工作就是确保你享受这一刻。确保你为你共同取得的成就感到自豪。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方，收听卡莉·劳埃德（Carly Lloyd）和珍妮·塔夫脱（Jenny Taft）主持的《不惜一切代价》（Whatever It Takes）。
Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecom. at the Adriah Health Institute in New York City. On this show, I'll be talking to top researchers and top clinicians, asking them your burning questions and bringing that information about women's health and midlife directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. It can be such a struggle for our quality of life, but even if it's natural, why should
欢迎收听《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特（Elizabeth Pointer）博士，纽约市阿特里亚健康研究所（Atria Health Institute）女性健康与妇科系主任。在这个节目中，我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，向他们提出你们最关心的问题，并将有关女性健康和中年期的信息直接带给你们。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。这对我们的生活质量来说可能是一种挣扎，但即使它是自然的，为什么我们应该
we suffer through it? The types of symptoms that people talk about is forgetting everything. I never used to forget things. They're concerned that, one, they're concerned that one, they're not. have dementia and the other one is do I have ADHD? There is unprecedented promise with regard to cannabis and cannabinoids to sleep better, to have less pain, to have better mood and also to have better day-to-day life. Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeartRadio app,
忍受它呢？人们谈论的症状类型包括健忘。我以前从不健忘。他们担心，第一，他们担心自己是不是患有痴呆症，另一个是，我是否有ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍）？在大麻和大麻素方面，对于改善睡眠、减轻疼痛、改善情绪以及改善日常生活，有着前所未有的前景。在iHeartRadio应用程序上收听伊丽莎白·波因特博士主持的《解码女性健康》，
Apple Podcasts are wherever you're listening now. So as I said, culture on the rise, sorry to scare you. It's true though. And that's because a big trigger, as I said, for these kinds of groups to emerge is periods of instability and periods of fear. And a big moment like that happened in recent history that sociologists have said acted as a major catalyst for the formation of thousands of new cults. And that thing was the pandemic. The pandemic was a perfect storm of fear, misinformation, loneliness, conspiracies about the government, a search for. for meaning and a search for freedom, like all kind of rolled into one, and it happened to so many
Apple Podcasts或你现在收听的任何地方。正如我所说，邪教正在兴起，抱歉吓到你了。但这是真的。这是因为，正如我所说，这类群体出现的巨大诱因是动荡时期和恐惧时期。在近代史上发生过这样一个重大时刻，社会学家称其为数千个新邪教形成的重大催化剂。那件事就是大流行。大流行是恐惧、错误信息、孤独、关于政府的阴谋论的完美风暴，是对意义的追寻和对自由的追寻，就像所有这些东西汇聚在一起，它发生在如此多
people. One of the biggest cults to come out of this was the sovereign citizens movement. I know in Australia, in Canada, New Zealand, Germany, membership in these groups skyrocketed. If you haven't heard of the sovereign citizens, they're essentially people who are deeply anti-government, but to an extreme degree, and they really believe that you shouldn't have to have to be. You shouldn't have to pay tax, you shouldn't have to follow certain laws, you shouldn't be subject to any kind of governmental authority. There is a massive sovereign citizen compound, or like I guess it's a hideout in rural Australia. And there was a huge case last year involving a member of this sovereign citizens movement who shot and killed two police officers. And if you're Australian,
的人身上。由此产生最大的邪教之一是“主权公民”运动。我知道在澳大利亚、加拿大、新西兰、德国，这些团体的成员人数激增。如果你没听说过主权公民，他们本质上是极度反政府的人，达到了极端的程度，他们真的认为你不应该必须是。你不应该必须纳税，你不应该必须遵守某些法律，你不应该受任何形式的政府权威管辖。在澳大利亚农村有一个巨大的主权公民大院，或者我想那是一个藏身处。去年发生了一起大案，涉及一名主权公民运动成员，他开枪打死了两名警察。如果你是澳大利亚人，
you'll know this case. His name is Desi Freeman. If you want to look it up, it was all over the news. But the thing, like, obviously, it's shocking when that happens, but it made quite a stir because a lot of people in that community were like, we had no idea. We had no idea these people were just like around the corner. So sovereign citizen cults on the rise, doomsday cults are another one that are on the rise, which honestly, I kind of get it. I kind of get it. It's hard to not feel like end times are upon us if you read the news. But perhaps one of the most famous cults on earth at the moment is the so-called cult of Trump. Some cult experts, mind control experts argue that Trump fits the definition of a cult leader through his promotion of, well, because he is
你会知道这个案子。他的名字叫德西·弗里曼（Desi Freeman）。如果你想查一下，新闻里到处都是。但事情是这样的，显然，当这种情况发生时令人震惊，但它引起了相当大的轰动，因为那个社区里的很多人都说，我们根本不知道。我们根本不知道这些人就在拐角处。所以主权公民邪教正在兴起，末日邪教是另一个正在兴起的邪教，老实说，我有点理解。我有点理解。如果你读新闻，很难不觉得末日即将来临。但也许目前地球上最著名的邪教之一是所谓的“特朗普邪教”。一些邪教专家、精神控制专家认为，特朗普通过宣扬，嗯，因为他是一个
a cult of personality. They point to his followers like intense devotion to him, his creation of an us versus them narrative, the use of truth social to spread a single truth about the world based on his views to his followers. He demands absolute loyalty. If you don't, if you're not loyal, you face ostracization, you face shame, you face maybe even violence. Some people call it political populism. Others say it is so much more dangerous than that. I guess it's the same sentiment, if I'm thinking about it, as like one person's freedom fighter is another person's terrorist. One person's cult, we might call the cult of Trump a cult, but that's another person's political. beliefs, and it's another person's, I don't know, it's another person's religion.
个人崇拜。他们指出他的追随者对他强烈的奉献，他创造了一种“我们对他们”的叙事，利用“真实社交”（Truth Social）向他的追随者传播关于世界的单一真相，基于他的观点。他要求绝对忠诚。如果你不这样做，如果你不忠诚，你就会面临排斥，面临羞辱，甚至可能面临暴力。有些人称之为政治民粹主义。另一些人则说它比那危险得多。我想如果我仔细想想，这和“一个人的自由战士是另一个人的恐怖分子”是同样的道理。一个人的邪教，我们可能会称特朗普邪教为邪教，但那是另一个人的政治信仰，是另一个人的，我不知道，是另一个人的宗教。
There are also wellness groups which have come under fire for being cults. I have to mention that. It's a wellness podcast. I have to talk about them. For example, the universal medicine cult, the One Taste cult, which promoted orgasmic collective meditation. You heard that right. Modern wellness cults often use social media to lure people in because they
还有一些健康团体因被视为邪教而受到抨击。我必须提到这一点。这是一个健康播客。我必须谈谈它们。例如，通用医学（Universal Medicine）邪教，One Taste邪教，它提倡集体性高潮冥想。你没听错。现代健康邪教经常利用社交媒体来诱骗人们，因为他们
market self-improvement solutions and life coaching sessions and group programs that make people feel seen and bring them into the fold. And then they offer alternative practices. Then they offer packages you can buy with money. There's often a guru who asks for like unquestioning trust. They claim to possess exclusive secrets to health, to wealth, to enlightenment. And then that money component is critical because money, like that is what feeds the cult. There is this financial aspect that is truly the main intention of this group. They're offering these new age health practices that promise big things that ask you to cut off toxic family members that ask you to do all this stuff and it's only going to cost you, you know, all your life savings.
推销自我提升方案、生活指导课程和团体项目，让人们感到被关注，并将他们拉入圈子。然后他们提供替代疗法。然后他们提供你可以花钱购买的套餐。通常有一个大师要求绝对的信任。他们声称拥有关于健康、财富、启蒙的独家秘密。然后金钱成分至关重要，因为金钱，这就是滋养邪教的东西。存在这种经济层面，这确实是该团体的核心意图。他们提供这些承诺重大成果的新时代健康疗法，要求你切断与有毒家庭成员的联系，要求你做所有这些事情，而这只会让你付出，你知道，你毕生的积蓄。
And these people get into serious trouble and they really do end up harming themselves. I think the only approach to people who find themselves in these groups is just unconditional empathy, not the people who start them, the people who find themselves in them. And I know this sounds controversial to say that, but I think we really have to understand and try and be empathetic of the fear and the desperation that drives people into these misinformation spaces. No one willingly wants to feel so petrified of the world around them that they part with their morals, part with thousands of dollars, distance themselves from their family, become only more isolated and scared. I have friends whose parents have been basically taken from them by online misinformation
这些人陷入了严重的麻烦，他们确实最终伤害了自己。我认为对于那些发现自己身处这些团体中的人，唯一的方法就是无条件的同情，不是对那些发起这些团体的人，而是对那些发现自己身处其中的人。我知道说这话听起来很有争议，但我认为我们真的必须理解并尝试同情那些驱使人们进入这些错误信息空间的恐惧和绝望。没有人愿意让自己对周围的世界感到如此恐惧，以至于他们放弃自己的道德，放弃数千美元，疏远家人，变得更加孤立和害怕。我有朋友的父母基本上被网上的错误信息
groups that we could call cults. And it's devastating. I think when you see it up close, you truly do understand how much, it's just fear is at the heart of all this and how much desperation and hopelessness that was created by the pandemic and by all these other movements that happened at the same time. Again, it returns to one of my main points I've been making over and over again. The way the cults are depicted makes them seem like this rare standout thing that we can gawk at and we can watch a two-hour documentary and think that's not normal, how stupid must you be to have joined that, but actually it's basic human psychology that gets people involved. And it's basic human psychology that's just been manipulated in a certain
团体从他们身边夺走了，我们可以称之为邪教。这太令人痛心了。我认为当你近距离观察时，你真的会明白，恐惧是这一切的核心，以及大流行和同时发生的所有其他运动所造成的绝望和无助感有多么严重。再次回到我反复强调的要点之一。邪教的描绘方式使它们看起来像是一种我们可以盯着看的罕见突出事物，我们可以看一部两小时的纪录片，然后想那不正常，加入那个的人得有多蠢，但实际上，是基本的人类心理让人们参与其中。是基本的人类心理被操纵在某个
direction. And we're fascinated by it. This is the final thing I want to touch on for this episode. You know, we've examined cult leaders. We've examined cult followers. We've put the spotlight on them. What about us? Let's turn the attention back to us. What is the psychology behind why we find cults so fascinating, I guess, as viewers? So I've been thinking about this a lot. I think cults offer a fascinating clash between our intrinsic human desire to belong and like the terrifying allure of absolute control from the cult leader. I think when we watch documentaries like this, we kind of all ask ourselves that question, which is like, could that have happened to me? There was this New York Times piece written last year that also talks about
方向上。我们对此着迷。这是我想在这一集中谈到的最后一点。你知道，我们审视了邪教领袖。我们审视了邪教追随者。我们把聚光灯对准了他们。那我们呢？让我们把注意力转回我们自己身上。我想，作为观众，我们觉得邪教如此迷人的心理是什么？所以我一直在思考这个问题。我认为邪教提供了一种迷人的冲突，介于我们内在的归属感渴望和邪教领袖绝对控制的恐怖诱惑之间。我认为当我们观看这样的纪录片时，我们都会问自己那个问题，那就是，这会发生在我身上吗？去年写的一篇《纽约时报》文章也谈到了
the fact that cults are compelling because it shows us that we are much more pliable and much more gullible than we think we are. There is a human vulnerability there that we recognize in ourselves. We know, like, we don't want to admit it, but we do. Also, I think cults contain, they contain almost every, everything that humans find psychologically irresistible to look at. They contain sex, power, belonging, charismatic. personality, secrecy, rebellion, money, danger. There is something voyeuristic about watching people fall into that without knowing and watch them surrender their individuality to a leader. Because there is this like, this danger. There is this danger and there is this like excitement
邪教之所以引人注目，是因为它向我们展示了我们比自己想象的要灵活得多，也容易受骗得多。那里有一种我们能在自己身上识别出的人类脆弱性。我们知道，就像，我们不想承认，但我们确实承认。此外，我认为邪教包含，它们几乎包含人类觉得心理上无法抗拒去观看的一切。它们包含性、权力、归属感、魅力型人格、秘密、叛逆、金钱、危险。看着人们在不知情的情况下陷入其中，看着他们向领袖交出自己的个性，有一种偷窥的快感。因为有这种危险。有这种危险，还有这种兴奋
about watching that, that we kind of forget like these are real people. These are real people. This happened to them. Finally, I think the reason we're so obsessed with Colts is the train wreck effect. This is something I read about in an article by the author Kristen Alia, she teaches at Brown University. And she speaks about how watching a cult collapse is like watching or seeing a car accident and just needing to take a look. It gives us the safety of observing extreme human behavior that's fascinating or extreme human suffering that's fascinating from a distance and not actually being harmed by it. It's so novel because we don't think it's going to happen to us. We hope we don't experience it. And we want to see it from the safety of our homes and from behind
看着这一切，我们有点忘记了这些人是真实的人。这些人是真实的人。这发生在了他们身上。最后，我认为我们如此痴迷于邪教的原因是“火车失事效应”。这是我在作者克里斯汀·阿利亚（Kristen Alia）的一篇文章中读到的，她在布朗大学任教。她谈到观看邪教崩溃就像观看或看到车祸，只是需要看一眼。它给了我们从远处观察迷人的极端人类行为或迷人的极端人类痛苦的安全性，而不会真正受到伤害。这太新奇了，因为我们认为它不会发生在我们身上。我们希望我们不会经历它。我们想在自己家中安全地、在门后观看
closed doors. We want to see how those decisions are made. We want to see how ordinary humans can be driven to do terrible things or join terrible things. A big part of this is also the cult leaders themselves, like they are fascinating because power is fascinating. Charisma, no matter how terribly it's used, is magnetic and it's intriguing to us as humans. Charles Manson, Jim Jones, they fascinate us because, like, what an insane ability to make people do such awful things. And part of us just wants to know how. it all comes back to our desire to understand our own human nature just a little bit more.
。我们想看看这些决定是如何做出的。我们想看看普通人是如何被驱使去做可怕的事情或加入可怕的事情的。这其中很大一部分也是邪教领袖本身，就像他们很迷人，因为权力是迷人的。魅力，无论被使用得多么糟糕，都是有磁性的，作为人类，我们对此很感兴趣。查尔斯·曼森（Charles Manson）、吉姆·琼斯（Jim Jones），他们让我们着迷，因为，那种让人做如此可怕事情的疯狂能力。我们的一部分只是想知道原因。这一切都归结为我们想要更多地了解自己的人性。
And that, my friends, is the psychology of cults. That's why we find them so fascinating. So before we end this episode, let me do a quick summary of what we've covered because we have discussed so much. We discussed how cults form the personality types of cult leaders, what distinguishes a cult from a religion or Taylor Swift from a cult, what makes people vulnerable to joining a cult what makes them difficult to leave, and the anatomy of modern day cults like the cult of Donald Trump or sovereign citizens. And of course, we examined our own relationship to cults
这就是，我的朋友们，邪教的心理学。这就是为什么我们觉得它们如此迷人。所以在我们结束这一集之前，让我快速总结一下我们所涵盖的内容，因为我们讨论了很多。我们讨论了邪教是如何形成的、邪教领袖的人格类型、什么区分了邪教和宗教，或者泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）和邪教的区别，什么使人们容易加入邪教，什么使他们难以离开，以及现代邪教的解剖，如唐纳德·特朗普（Donald Trump）邪教或主权公民。当然，我们审视了我们自己与邪教的关系
and why we can't look away, why we can't help but stare and ponder. So thank you for listening. If you have made it all the way to the end, I hope you learned something. And if you are listening on Spotify, leave a comment down below. What do you think is a modern day cult? Mine is Tradwives. I think Tradwives is a modern day cult movement. Controversial, I know, but I just believe it. So leave a comment down below, what is yours? Make sure that you watch an episode on Netflix. If you haven't yet, that would be very, very helpful. You can also follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Thank you as always to our researcher for this episode, Lucy Davidson. There are heaps of other pieces of research in the
以及为什么我们无法移开视线，为什么我们忍不住盯着看并思考。所以谢谢你们的收听。如果你已经坚持到了最后，我希望你学到了一些东西。如果你是在Spotify上收听，请在下方留下评论。你认为什么是现代邪教？我的是“传统妻子”（Tradwives）。我认为“传统妻子”是一种现代邪教运动。我知道这很有争议，但我就是这么认为的。所以请在下方留下评论，你的是什么？确保你在Netflix上观看了一集。如果你还没看，那会非常有帮助。你也可以在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast。一如既往地感谢我们这一集的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）。还有很多其他的研究资料在
description of this episode if you want to go even further. There's also a link to our substack where we put shorter transcript versions of these episodes in reading format that we send to your email. So if you like to read whilst you listen, that is a great way to do it. I think that's all my little reminders. I just hope you enjoyed this episode. I need a big glass of water after all that research. So I hope it was worth it. And until next time, be safe. Be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health and Gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top
这一集的描述中，如果你想深入了解的话。还有一个链接到我们的Substack，我们在那里以阅读格式发布这些剧集的较短文字版本，并发送到你的电子邮件。所以如果你喜欢在听的时候阅读，那是一个很好的方式。我想这就是我所有的小提醒了。我只是希望你喜欢这一集。做了这么多研究后，我需要一大杯水。所以我希望这是值得的。下次见，注意安全。要善良，对自己温柔。我们很快就会再谈。欢迎收听《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特博士，纽约市阿特里亚健康研究所女性健康与妇科系主任。我将与顶尖的
researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the I-Heart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal, Carl thought he was living a normal, drama-free life until the messages started. Someone's not going to make it out of this alive. Every piece of evidence pointed to the wrong guy.
研究人员和临床医生交谈，并将有关中年女性健康的重要信息直接带给你们。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。即使它是自然的，为什么我们应该忍受它呢？在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方，收听伊丽莎白·波因特博士主持的《解码女性健康》。你毁了我。你不配得到幸福。我是安德里亚·甘宁（Andrea Gunning）。在这一季的《背叛》（Betrayal）中，卡尔（Carl）以为自己过着正常、没有戏剧性的生活，直到那些信息开始出现。有人不会活着走出这里。每一条证据都指向了错误的人。
He was not going to stop unless we stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Is there an epidemic against literature? More specifically, black literature. I'm Jack Quist-Peace Thomas, and on this season of the Black Lits podcast, we're outside asking why. They don't want a whole bunch of little Ella bakers, Malcolm Rexes and Martin with the Kings running around. And when you look at a lot of different cultures, they're like, we need to know where you came from. And considering this is Black Reading Month, they don't even.
除非我们阻止他，否则他不会停止。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方，收听《背叛》第六季。是否存在针对文学的流行病？更具体地说，针对黑人文学。我是杰克·奎斯特-皮斯·托马斯（Jack Quist-Peace Thomas），在这一季的《黑人文学》（Black Lits）播客中，我们正在外面询问原因。他们不想要一大堆小埃拉·贝克（Ella Bakers）、马尔科姆·X（Malcolm Xes）和马丁·路德·金（Martin Luther Kings）到处跑。当你观察许多不同的文化时，他们会说，我们需要知道你来自哪里。考虑到这是黑人阅读月，他们甚至不。
real question is, what are you reading next? Listen to Black Lit from the Black Effect Podcast Network on our iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. If anyone wanted to commit a murder, up here would be the greatest place in the world to hide the body. But no one will find it. He acted friendly. He talked friendly. He sounded friendly. They all knew that I did the scary boogie stuff, and I said, maybe she'll find out where this girl is.
真正的问题是，你接下来要读什么？在我们的iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方，收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《黑人文学》。如果有人想谋杀，这里将是世界上隐藏尸体的最佳地点。但没有人会找到它。他表现得很友好。他说话很友好。他听起来很友好。他们都知道我做了可怕的鬼怪事情，我说，也许她会发现这个女孩在哪里。
I saw him violent. Backhanded a pow! Listen to the Devil's Quarry Season 2 in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Fox Sports Reporter Jenny Taft. And I'm former U.S. Women's National Soccer team player,
我看到他暴力。反手一巴掌，砰！在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方，收听《魔鬼采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）第二季的Bone Valley频道。我是福克斯体育记者珍妮·塔夫脱。我是前美国国家女子足球队队员，
Carly Lloyd. And on our new podcast, whatever it takes, nothing is off limits. I played with players that didn't truly love the game. I found the love with the love with the ball at my foot. I don't care what I'm being asked to do at Fox. I'm going to go get some reps
卡莉·劳埃德。在我们的新播客《不惜一切代价》中，没有什么是不可以谈论的。我和那些并不真正热爱这项运动的球员一起踢球。我在脚下有球的时候找到了爱。我不在乎福克斯要求我做什么。我要去多做些练习
and love it and embrace it. Listen to whatever it takes with Carly Lloyd and Jenny Taft on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并热爱它并拥抱它。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方，收听卡莉·劳埃德和珍妮·塔夫脱主持的《不惜一切代价》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。